ja c'est une bonne chose le raid qui est
lancé à leur aide est lancé on récente
que soit fonctionne à faire les choses
par étapes aujourd'hui on est d'accord
tout marche bien
maintenant je vais appeler fable du coup
je fais je je règle les choses les unes
après les autres
beaucoup plus malins qui hier où je me
suis retrouvé dans la sauce total et
aujourd'hui ça va pas être le cas le
français ne va pas être dans la sauce le
français ne va pas être dans la sauce
aujourd'hui salut fabre et mon temps en
temps ça fonctionne
attends je vais pas être dans l'océan je
vais peut être dans la sauce attends je
suis un peu dans la sauce mais pas trop
par contre la caméra fonctionne pas pour
moi sonics jette jette un oeil
je te laisse jeter un oeil toute façon
j'ai les caméras à faire donc regarde
c'est peut-être dans l'est dans les
dents les settings puisque toute façon
je rajouter les deux autres caméras pour
le moment donc à le temps d'enlever le
cache non non elle est l ai écrit
peut-être qu'elle a activé sur un autre
programme jette un oeil
bah je sais pas s'il a fallu bien qu'ils
me montrent que ces marchés ouais alors
après peut-être qu'elle fonctionne
peut-être que les joueurs peut-être
qu'elle est allumée en réalité mais que
je veux dire la cij mais je coupe la
caméra danga août le bouton vert c'est
un si jeune âge là bim bam le bouton
vert s'allume regard qu'ils apprennent
vérifie qu'ils soient bien la bonne
sinon tant pis il y aura pas de bail dès
qu'une caméra ça va pas être ça
fonctionne escale ça va ça va savait que
7e place ça va pas ça va pas aller mais
de toute façon soit pas venir de je sais
pas comment faire attendre
je suis dit que si je suis là je suis en
train de rendre encore plus lorsqu'on
sait qu'on les ait chaque après si tu me
partage d'écran je vais devoir tout
partager aussi ça ça va je suis en train
de je fais le mien je fais les caméras
des joueurs en fait donc atteint faut
que je me concentre et je dois écouter
si le son logo et le son combien d'une
autorisation pour tenir marche vers la
droite en tentant faut vraiment que je
me concentre là je suis en train de
faire n'importe quoi
donc si je suis en train de faire
n'importe quoi
alors j'ai récupéré hikaru déjà je vais
récupérer maintenant maxime
hop donc ça ça va être bon j'ai récupéré
les joueurs et je vais faire la
transition
ok du coup maintenant je suis plus à
même de discuter parce qu'avant j'étais
tellement sur le truc que je suis à
ouais si monde qui l'allument s'ils
montrent qu'ils allument tu veux qu'on
essaye de renvoyer un appel on sait
jamais je passais quelqu un qu une idée
dans le tchat
voilà j'ai complètement perdu fab
j'entends plus faibles les gars j'ai
besoin d'un bon je vais je vais mettre
le suivi des joueurs pour pas rater le
début du match
jérôme thion la période bon c'est pas
grave séparables égard on va rester
concentré il faut peut-être redémarrer
le pc à mince du coup attendez j'ai le
chat hills mais là ok le chat je dois à
l'éteindre
ok je suis concentré en tout cas je suis
concentré tu pensé quoi les oreilles
c'est du 50-50 à une finale une finale
c'est toujours 50 50 les amis
saint-quentin n'y a pas de maxime a
battu 1-3 que fall est de retour allez
peut-être qu'il a quitté la pelle il est
revenu parce que google hangouts et un
truc bien c'est que ça laisse donc le
match qui va bientôt bientôt se lancer
ouais c'est ça il est il est parti va
revenir comment je vais faire ça comme
ça el ouali ouais ça les ferait en temps
on te rends temps fab je ne sais pas
pourquoi c'est parti je sais pas quoi
faire on va laisser ça comme ça pour le
moment en début de match histoire de
bien le faire je vais te mettre le
partage d'écran et puis
et puis tu m'entends toujours
c'était arrivé à tout cas ça fait ça
fait tout bug à la jemaye entend
toujours
ouais je tends tendance était partie
ménages temps en temps mais j'ai
toujours pas le partage
ouais alors attends je te levais à temps
assez terrible mais il trouverait un
truc horrible dans les ménages
non non non non non mais je sais pas là
comme ça pas marche au début et que j'ai
plein de trucs là c'est là c'est
terrible à tant cetime saison le match
qui est parti
le match qui est partie fab avec une
sicilienne d'entrée pour maxime alors il
va y avoir une stratégie de match
complètement différente aujourd'hui
ouais moi par rapport à hier maxime qui
disait hier après le match que qu'il
avait joué très tactique contre contre
carl ce n est que aujourd'hui du coup il
allait devoir employer une stratégie de
match complètement différente parce que
c'était finalement le point fort fa le
point faible entre guillemets de
carlsson était le point fort de dix cars
ou et donc qu'il allait falloir un une
stratégie de match complètement
différente face faso face aux joueurs
américains quoi basse à kicker voudrais
te laisse pas trop de celle et les
tactiques mais bon qui sait mon truc
c'est que maxime quand même il est bon
aussi là dedans quoi ouais il laisse pas
passer les tricks soit il laisse pas
passer les tricks
et je pense que maxime il est peut-être
un petit peu en dessous quoi c'est être
le seul joueur du monde hikaru à être
au-dessus de lui dans les tricks c'est
peut-être y croit on à vélo d'or très
fort dans les bullet et ça serait bien
d'avoir un petit peu d'avancé avant
cette cette portion ouais tout à fait
tout à fait là contre hikaru il faudrait
un peu comme hier
hier contre magnus faudrait entamer avec
2,3 points d'avance et finalement avec
la dynamique de match et le début des
bullet ça devrait lui donner un vrai
avantage parce que hier magnus avait
quand même la dynamique du match contre
lui au début des bulles est donc même si
les plus forts intrinsèquement après
trois heures de jeu
ça fait mal quoi ouais puis quant à la
confiance ou quoi c'est quelque chose
exactement tout cas là il est en dessous
il vient de jouer un petit dames c'est
cette maxime et c'est une position de
sicilienne
assez assez classique non fardé
sicilienne avec détroit s'ils viennent
fermer je pense qu on appelle ça comme
ça ouais c'est sa c4 3e ça c'est une
petite variante
koutchma bhl qui tous ressembler à un
d'ouverture parce que la structure peu
évolué au centre est et nord font des 5
et blanc sont de 5 sur une tête de
française si les noirs font aussi ce 5e
même plus d'évolution d'italien ou
d'espagnol
donc c'est une ouverture intéressante
ventes intéressantes que les blancs aime
bien jouer justement pour rester pour la
souplesse
alors est-ce que aussi un jour un petit
cd pour vous la colonne c'est possible
après détours ses huit c'est clairement
dans les plantes pour ça qu'il a fait
comme ça ça ne veut pas
du coup il a poussé il s'en prend aux
cavaliers un cavalier plusieurs options
alors déjà s comprend avant premier est
ce qu'on prend pas souvent on prend mais
m'écoute pourquoi pas valide et de
pousser c'est très clair c'est que
voulez vous c'est le et ça donne la case
de 4 aussi pour prendre une place
éventuellement notamment aux cavaliers
doivent donc pour ça c'est pas mal les
carreaux et caro qui est tranquille
inquiet de nouveaux locaux tsm juste
pour dire apparemment je crois qu'il
joue en tout ces tours h et tsm son
petit frigo rouge
ouais avec la machine à café
frigo qui est une machine à café en fait
je crois ou c'est la raison d'un frigo
et je ne sais plus dans quel sens mais à
ses dents longues dans l'eau des gogos
c'est soit frigo sa machine à café des
structures peuvent elles changer c'est
pour avoir une connexion parfaite on
nous dit ça c'est sûr que s'il ya une
fibre connecter directement à autre
chose comme depuis ta famille les biens
donc j'ai appris à la structure a changé
donc il ya quoi y'a père de fou pour
icare où il ya les avantages des deux
fous dans une position ouverte mais un
petit peu d'activités côté maxime il a
terminé le développement il a ses pièces
installées au centre bell exactement bon
après mon séjour pression je ne peux pas
trop mal avec les blancs ça aurait
vraiment être important à le début de
match je pensais encore plus important
contre hikaru que contre que contre
magnus parce que comme ça je voulais
tricks j'ai l'impression que lorsque tu
tu commences à prendre l'ascendant ou au
contraire quand ton adversaire prend
l'ascendant ça fait encore plus mal
psychologiquement parce possible côtière
enfin j'ai vu que ça a commencé par 2-0
et puis que max et oublie remontée pas
gêner enchaîné quoi il a après il a il a
une période où il a mieux joué il a pris
l'avantagé d'un point à trois et demi
deux et demi je crois puis après il ya
une période où c'est plutôt magnus qui a
bien joué mais sans jamais conclure
après ces deux nouveaux maxime qui a
mieux joué mais sans vraiment trop
reprendre davantage et il s'est retrouvé
que à +2 donc il cette longue période où
les joueurs n'ont pas concrétiser leurs
temps forts et finalement salle en
bullet ou maxime l'a commencé à dérouler
les monte à plus 4 il nous a fait un
petit peu peur en fin de match mais là
je vais complètement réglé il a pas fait
je joue je vous la montrer qu'on panique
alors il l'a pas fait mais il a annoncé
il a annoncé hier sur la chaîne que
contre hikaru il le ferait cette annonce
est d'ailleurs il a annoncé aussi qu'il
aimait pas trop le format hier sur la
chaîne terrible pour daniel reyne ce
désaveu désaveu compliqué pour pour pour
l'organisateur américain
donc est ce qui va peut être est ce que
tu penses qu'il veut faire un carré
laissé cinq tours j'ai 4 max est ce que
ce serait pas dans le style de marloux
de notre maxime pourquoi pas en tout cas
très clairement la cour qui peut
coulisser là bas jouer à deux avec son
site 17 dans ces huit qui se gardent
peut-être db4 à un moment mais bon je
continue a plutôt préféré les blancs
avec cette histoire de peur de fou ouais
7c tour sur la colonne c'est qui du coup
pour le moment peuvent pas trop jouer
sans un coup comme b4 qui ouvrirait mais
les noirs ont vraiment le problème de
ces cases noires proche du roi ce qu'ils
sont orphelins de leur leur fout du
chantier tôt nous habitons à l'esat ça
semble plus sympa à jouer pour les
blancs après position est extrêmement
compliqué ouais pourquoi c'est pas mal
de choses mais voilà perdre aux choux
nous passions un peu ouvert c'est
quasiment comme tu le signalait c'est
pas mal du fait même des deux justement
encore fois justice et on a du mal à
toucher les blanque fougasse ici pour un
plus enchaîné avec un dan des 4es et
viser vraiment cette casse g7
ça a l'air difficile ça a l'air très
difficile pour pour maxime qui a et c 5
jouer donc il attaque le four b3 le fou
qui vient ans ces deux donc le cavalier
qui contrôlent énormément de casa
présent tour 17
la tour qui vient se mettre en vis-à-vis
en face de la dame maxime qui luttent
ils voulaient peut-être essayer un
cavalier b4 car il ya eu 5 qui arrive et
il attaque la tour la turquie qui repart
en c'est cette maxime qui est vraiment
sous pression de cavalier blanc qui va
peut-être jaillir sur une case g4 les
amis et viser du cavalier m6 ou du
cavalier six essais dont joueurs là pour
pour le joueur français qui est en
énorme en énorme difficulté dans cette
partie mais pour le moment qui tient
grâce à ses deux cavaliers qui sont qui
sont centraux allait l'obliger de
chasser le cavalier 4 mais c'est de plus
en plus compromettants pour pour pour
les noirs lecavalier qui revient aux 5
et
le pion g6 qui est qui attaque et
maintenant les sacrifices accotements
raison avec le pion aux six au total est
au max qui amène à damman sondes pitot
alors c'est assez rare de ma foi
pourquoi est ce que ça te tiens on verra
pareil l'aï réussi à couvrir pour le
moment son roi avec avec la dame
il essaye de se débarrasser d'une pièce
blanche en a eu cinq ce cavalier qui est
une pièce offensive et c'est d'échanger
les pièces faire le dos rond et
peut-être en finale tirée là nul pour le
moment c'est c'est un peu l'espoir de
prendre un demi point ici à fab on vas
tu as raison c'est un peu le mieux qu'on
puisse aller chercher après que tu as
une gaffe ça peut arriver en face mais
ouais on est un bourg souffrance avec
ses murs dans cette position après un
jour il suffit d'un cavalier f4 qui
partent avec une prison j'ai deux ça
peut aussi aller très vite un de l'autre
côté est plus qu'une minute pour les
deux hommes
première partie déjà très tendu au
hikaru qui envoie une pièce et qu'il
fait tout reprend il a calculé jusque là
la variante était quasiment forcé il ya
le cavalier en l'air enfin en l'air se
mit en l'air parce qu'on perdrait on va
sur avec une qualité de plus hors
peut-être ce qui part pour du roi 7 pour
le moment
ah mais attends sur un rouage satie
serait dans le viseur c'est sûr c'est
intéressant ce qu'il a fait car où on a
envie de sacrifier à leur tour 17 hockey
et ce qu'il veut prendre et four b3
qu'est-ce qu'il en tête
en tout cas ça à double tranchant à ce
sacrifice d'hikaru sur des fous b3 et on
pourra faire peut-être un tour ses
quatrains d'ailleurs si jamais dame g5
justin que menace-t-il de tout bas g6 et
des 5 mg si ces dessins qui l'attaquent
g6 et des 5 maxime qui les protège et
protège les six et il protège des 5
alors attends maintenant maxime il a
juste une pièce de plus ouais alors il
ya des filles qui traîne toujours le
fameux four b3 alors sur le four b3 on a
peut-être un cavalier c4 on te dire on
prend un petit peu mais pas trop sur le
f 4 on a peut-être des cavaliers g41 on
va avoir la réponse
où il y avait son guembri arrive c'est
peut-être cette il attaque la dame s'il
fait ça ils soient d'alger 3 un peu
triste saddam pranger si ces trois pions
pour les pièces mais pour combien de
temps se prête à quai avec 4 mai ville
de laval y en a eu trois s'agit de
regarder mais c'est pas con cinq
attaques et contre attaques autre chose
il atteint il atteint carrément tout
c'est plus ans et d'au maximum pas
reculer il avant soit le petit fou échec
mais est ce que c'est un bon coup cet
échec
maxime qui réfléchit à tour ces quatre
peut-être naïf et 3h cette voie là c'est
le clash mais il est mieux placé pour
ses 5 fu g3 alors on en est ou
matériellement on a une qualité d'eau
pure mais deux pions à une menace d'un
proche 5 attention ce petit coup de
barre loup ça va peut-être finir en
perpète
je crois qu'il va la jouer en quart ou
qui jouent la finale
mais attention il peut la perdre un
carrousel là la tour qui peut jaillir en
d2 pour des offres à yaffo f4 olala
c'est terrible tu l'as dit au moment où
tu as dit a pas de tours d2 moi je dis
tour d2 il a joué il a perdu la pièce en
un et c'est exactement le scénario
inverse fable comme on le comme on le
pressentait du dumas d'hier c'est-à-dire
classée même maxime je dirais qui a
finalement dominé la phase complexe mais
c'est lui qui craquent en premier ouais
mais écoute on va voir alors la finale à
berne c'est pas mal je veux care mc si
vous avez gagné contre comme carl saint
louis ouais il a sorti une grosse partie
écoute je sais c'est pas mal je souhaite
ricard où on va voir on va voir la
propos de joueurs américains
il me semble que maxime avait battu
aarau là dessus je suis peut-être aux
derniers sketchs king open où il en
avait gagné il en avait gagné une messe
est votre explication
de toute façon il y aura une explication
dans cette berlinoise parce que 6 cars
ou est obligé de changer de d'ouverture
avec les noirs il se retrouvera en grand
danger face à maxime c'est sa faute elle
berlinoise cesson c'est son rempart j'ai
envie de dire sur lequel il peut se
reposer depuis bien longtemps
ça fait des années qu'on voit je sais
maintenant et si sa caste qui perd une
partie de partis trois parties et devra
changer ou pas prendre l'eau toute la
soirée
mais du coup ce sera moins solides ce
qui choisira quoi qu'il en soit ce
rapace en arme numéro un ouais ce sera
ce sera un problème donc ses premières
parties là dans la berlinoise sont
vraies
en primordial dans ce match si maxime
réussi à aller mettre sous pression et à
en gagner au moins deux sur trois il
forcera quasiment hikaru à changer
d'armes ans avec les noirs et il prendra
un avantage clair dans toutes les
parties à venir et que les blancs et les
faits ces quatre ils donnent ils donnent
le pion s'aimer pour pour créer des
pions triplé chez les noirs sais c'est
pas assez rare un convoi ce genre de
position elle est triple ouais des pions
triplé face à un seul pion le pion c2
qui bloque les plus explosifs c4c 6 et 7
fautes en avoir puisque attaque pour max
et que sa tour des quatre étapes les
coulisses et l'on peut prendre ces
quatre peut-être partir notre côté ces
trois jouets d'accord est ce que ceci
fait ce qui est un tour ces quatre ans
il le faire ok donc il s'en passe durant
fais du foot sur dangereux mais il a vu
qu'il y avait pas de découverte on a
taxé 6 et puis tu as an sur lequel il
découvre il est toujours calé en food
donc pas de gros risques pour l'instant
donc je sais que j'ai pas la cam mais je
sais pas pourquoi c'est réseau légal
c'est comme ça je suis dans la remontons
chiot double ça va récupérer peut-être
une photo à la pause en fait vous je
pense que c'est ce que je vais faire à
la peau je mettrai une photo juste là on
va se concentrer sur le match va pas
perdre cinq minutes parce que ça me
paraît ça ça me paraît vraiment bon mais
peu importe en a je me disais que tu roi
17 il ya un truc sur l'iss et qu'il
prendrait vii vii fou prend à j-6
peut-être et s'ils réussissaient à
claques à 1 au 6 mai j'ai maintenant ça
marche pas ce qu'elle est une bonne
position avec les blancs il aime bien il
aime bien j'ai un truc mais c'est
vraiment une en affrontements souvent
cette vente entre les deux anglais de
georges pas comme une toile bon joueur
il perd souvent les tours prend 6,6 me
paraît ultra intéressant parce pas
d'être le coup qu'on a envie de faire en
tout cas alors qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire et carulla dessus ou est-ce que
c'est tombé 1
il faudra aussi se méfier des tourbes et
de gangs bon pour l'instant je crois que
ce sera inutile et enfin vous prend et
c'est pas grave mais ça peut parfois
être une idée un jour enfin pas vraiment
sur tourbe et on a juste un petit roi f2
non
on protège ça semble correct pour maxime
cette position je pense qu'elle est
importante cette partie à mettre la tête
sous l'eau avec les noirs et d'hikaru
directement pas à pas le laisser rentrer
dans le match s'installer j'ai pas j'ai
pas envie de revoir un 2 0 en faveur de
l'adversaire aujourd'hui fab
non je pense qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment arrêter l'hémorragie pour
ensuite jouer est ce qu'il veut faire
cuire 5 sinon je me pose la question
opposer les changes soit sixième rang
j'ai attaqué ces deux mais surtout elle
s'inquiète pour ses cinq retours pour
attaquer le cavaliere
j'aimerais je sais pas trop ce qu'il
fasse cavalier ou alors je sais pas si
c'est très compliqué comme positionne
comme position ses membres s'étaient
vite très vite une finale il n'y a plus
trop de pièces mais il y en a un peu de
partout et les décisions sont
importantes commencent à terme menacer
des carafes cette fois ci c'est un petit
à petit la gamme qui peuvent tomber pas
tout de suite encore mais ça mais ça
peut aussi être un truc qui peut arriver
ok donc tourbières il l'a fait bref de
commandes avait dit pas où les postes
seulement de suite mais mes études
écologiques de part et d'autre alors
peut-être que 3d c'était un coup c'est
pas brader cette nouvelle un coup
peut-être un tour à si ceux-ci
impossible tout le temps avec des idées
de 44 cas et ses cinq tours à cette
genre de truc il ya camaïeu 4 6 3 au 6
qui menacent bêtement d'ailleurs pas
tout à fait ton c3 il était pas là pour
toujours
rodez saint john ok bon pour l'instant
il courut sont plus ou moins logiques
après il ya pas mal de choix donc il
faut faire les bons et on est dans sa
tour à 6 alors maxime a reculé
simplement en c5
il se garde maintenant et progressiste
peut être comme menace parce que tour
n'était pas possible donc il est parti
logique très logique sans vis-à-vis du
phocéen et le peut-être partir
simplement sur la colonne b il fait la
gueule d'un super super super et attaque
le pion il va sur les problèmes
d'effectivement il peut gagner le pion
pour les blancs pis le gagne après fou
de couleur reposer le problème c'est que
le pion plus des blancs
achat du mal à avancer parce que les
noirs contrôler cette case g4 mais
peut-être qu'un jour ou f3 les bras et
des alors ils menacent je serai un
instant mais se place alors comment est
ce que les blancs vont réagir et ce
qu'ils vont faire un coût de
développement de fou un fouet quattro il
fait rage sinko pour le moment il a
vanté son pion c'est vrai que pas bête
ouais un jour c'est vrai que s'il s'en
prend à se plonger et qui doit faire
j'ai six 6 h 6 sa gagne tout de suite
hein voilà ça c'est clair t'as raison
donc h5 c'est pas mal il a profité de
lancer son pion sur une pièce blanche
tant qu'il est pas bloqué il veut
peut-être tour des 3 et où ils peuvent
être un peu juste un tour des trois
tours des huit genre de truc 1 et tours
g8 ça peut aller vraiment très très vite
un côté maxime à dakar ou réagir
immédiatement il laisse pas maxime
s'infiltrait fouet 4 mai voire trois
échanges à et surtout gk tuera peut-être
de6 avoir un pour trois ans probablement
échanges problème en échange pourrait
clairement je sais pas trop pourquoi
faut-il d'une tour c'est fou j'ai
caressé vraiment la ligne critique
donc si l'on veut prendre du roi
j'imagine comme ça surtout en français 7
il ya plus d'échecs et on croise 5
maxime prend à 7
il y aura des pions bastide et un peu de
partout mais c'est pas mal puisque les
deux tours c'est si ces intermédiaires
attend 3 5 est ce qu'il ya un trick à il
veut tour ses sept tours f7 et tour à
cette victoire 5-1 on défend un obstacle
mais en tout cas on prend sa tête ça
c'est alors à temps est-ce qu'il ya pas
un conte intrigue encore plus plus
méchant je sais pas moins ses quatre
intermédiaires tu vois bref à j-6
intermédiaire bon faut le prendre
j'imagine ah oui d'accord et quand tu
fais tout reprend ses sept du coup c'est
double attaque
double take software 500 qu elle fermait
peinture acheter facilement que tu as à
tour à 5
il se garde à sept ont par ailleurs
lancé logique hein
eh bien je pense que c'est nul 1 1 parce
que là tu récupères h6 quand même mais
ça qui est bloqué il évoquait un cargo
qui fait une belle défense en tout cas
ils souffrent dans cette permanence
c'est pas ça pas de tout repos pour lui
c'est parti là était noir même si tiens
cela alors il a eu vent qui peut partir
mais il n'ira pas bien loin
alors la foudre couloir oppose elle doit
être nul à cause de la règle de la
diagonale les noirs doivent pouvoir
arrêter les pions sur la même diagonale
avec leur fou donc si on échange et les
tours ça doit être nul en tout cas ses
carnets mur tu as c'est une règle du
carnet way où il y aussi la lucarne
alors non il n'avait pas de carnet mais
c'est baky qui appelle ça des carnets
maintenant dès que tu dis avec deux murs
tassou de vlad il te dit carnet à une
menace ah non ils menacent pas si
j'avais le roi f3 il menacerait j'ai
quatre matches mais il peut pas il peut
pas le faire j'allais dire si le fou
partir je commençais à rêver d'un math
baky c'est possible en découdre oppose
ouais ouais faut dire quoi août aura
trois quarts où je sais pas exactement
pour à 3 jouer mais c'est pas pour vous
brokaw il a que 30 secondes
mais quand même moins lourd sur
l'échiquier
et puis il y réussit à remettre la
marche avant oui il peut gagner maxime
saint germain sans attaquer sans faire
tomber
non sans les tours ça irait pam avec les
tours ça peut se gagner un
il fait passer 5 pour le moment encore
ces quatre pardon pour ces 5 7 tours
détroit le jeune mais mon de soissons il
montera williams est 5e à l'écart ou qui
envoie le con tre jeu il a bien raison
pour insiste gérard wey accroît
probatoire au bep cap avec à tour des
quatre j'imagine
il faut se tient dans ses trois volets
seront bien sûr puisque on aimerait
quand même pousser les pions
bah faudrait le mettre dans ces cinq au
moins pour qu'il soit sur noir alors
tour à sacha les propos marlou mais
rejeté quatre bien joué
qu'est ce qu'on peut améliorer l'info et
cinq bien jouer il faut 5 très bien joué
et maintenant roi b4 et jouer à but non
pas ce cap à tourbes et 8 échecs et
surtour s'est vite on va pouvoir faire
ces 5 et vous des six as oui si tu
commences à être là là tu vas commencer
à être gagnant ya passé cinq un tournant
le c4 sûr que le font avec 4 à la tour
au cas pour le karaté
ouais ouais il a bien trouvé ce coup de
tours 8 qu'est-ce qu'on fait des quatre
maintenant mon père j'ai trois simples
new g3 est si grave
bah c'est pas que ces faits graves mais
ils préfèrent france et 4 enfin il s'en
va ce roman c'est 6 mai mais au pire au
pire observaient toujours ça mais encore
faut-il faire nul avec tours contours
flous en fait il trouve que c'est nul
théorique
malheureusement il car où va la défendre
normalement celle là bon c'est quand
même maxime qui continuent à presser ya
peu de temps un côté car où il ya que
plus une seconde 1 je tiens à le
signaler
le plus une seconde est quand même très
très léger effectué peut perdre large tu
peux facilement perdre un tour fou
contre tours dans cette cadence là mais
bon je vois pas s'il va être obligé de
le faire parce que peut-être et le chou
et la tour qui défendent ces six essais
de clerc de les déloger sans faire des
changes mais en place il va divapour
qu'il y arrive quand même hein parce que
maxime avance maximum avant sur instance
et sociétaux aussi c'est ce qui fait 3 6
me fout il reste toujours aussi ça le
problème
comment on n'arrive pas à avancer plus
loin
oui car oui défend vite hein parce qu'il
a tellement peu de temps sur sa pendule
le streamer américains qui eux qui monte
c'est que j'ai un passé ses qualités
sous ristic et sa force et sa force
quand il a peu de temps
max qui réussit pas
à à percer l'actrice américaine là pour
expliquer l'enjeu de la position les
blancs en tête grimpions en plus il
faudrait arriver à leur niveau pour
transformer en dames et le problème
c'est qu'on a le bar rolex et si ça
passait mais c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile parce que voilà ouais c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer
mais ok il va réussi à 3,17 envoyé à
temps mais ouais tour f4 là c'est bien
là ce qui fait maxime là c'est très bien
ce qui fait ça y est il y réussit pas
encore à l'envoyer mais il lui met la
pression il peut pas faire un petit
faiseur savez la cam marche à ça et on a
enfin laissé récupérer caméra c'est
pourquoi j'ai pas ce que j'ai fait
différent mais bon mais moi ça va je
sors de l'ombre
la caméra qui fonctionne il faut que je
récupère maintenant picard hooper parole
à l'ouverture
wei carreaux qui repart dans la même
ouverture et maxime aussi bien
d'ailleurs
ouais ouais il joue de la nouvelle dame
7,7 et ya un mois mais je veux ou cinq
ici wells a poussé les mêmes coûts mais
il fait la même chose je suis étonné
parce que je pensais que c'était bien
pour les manceaux mais du coup j'imagine
que maxime pense que pour lui tout est
ok donc il a une autre évaluation de la
position et je vais bien bah il refait
pas le truc avec j'ai 6 ans il avait eu
de gros problèmes sur cases noires airs
défend pas avec heroes défend avec la
structure avec avec g 7 h 6 c'est quand
même assez logique
et là ils ont ils envoient d'un f4 donc
c'est que juste de manière très concrète
qu'il a réussi à améliorer son jeu
baky qui doit être au taquet qui direct
fait d'écrire elle n'a par exemple pas
le droit pendant le hajj sont pas loin
entre les entre les entre les matches
mais peut prendre entre les segments oui
mais pas pas pendant un segment ce qui a
son importance et qui explique les
changements de d'ouverture entre les
segments en réalité ça arrive parfois
mais est ce qui ce qui explique que les
joueurs changent parfois de d'ouverture
entre les segments
bon là ça va il a réussi à s'activer ça
compense la perte de fou probablement
les banques avaient lieu 5 pénible
malheureusement je préfère toujours les
blancs brrr ça peut être que les
cavaliers aussant qui compense en fait
on cherchait que toi tu as souvent
l'habitude je le sais position autant de
verser à la paire de fouetter un chat
mais ça va normalement en fait c'est pas
si grave
surtout si tu as une belle case comme la
casse des 5 oui voilà c'est la raison
pour laquelle maxime autorise ce sera
pour matériel mais bon je trouve pas
hyper impression on est à l'aise par ya
peut-être naturelles et la tour ans et 8
après comment tu joues avec les blancs
ici je ferai tout bien mon histoire
d'amitié des muses histoire et puis tu
fais rien de spécial mais peut-être tu
peux suivent et rossé 4 un moment qui
mâche un coin c'est pas facile à faire
mais trois constantes qui ont pedu il
est fixé le défense et 3 donkament
souvent le problème dans ses positions
avec les noirs c'est pas vraiment le
fait que tu sois moins bien mais c'est
le fait que t'es pas de plan ça qui est
pénible faut bien ne rien faire ouais
c'est ça c'est que c'est dur d'améliorer
puisque si tu commences à avancer tu vas
tu vas perdre des cases et si tu bouges
pas bon il faut bien que parfois il faut
bien ne pas bouger en fait exactement
et c'est pas forcément facile et sachant
que peut-être finalement pas non plus
fantastique mais à mon sens aix cahier
des cinq écoutes auquel hélas pas là il
est parti pour revenir un jour
tant qu'il est là il tient quand même
pas mal la baraque oui deux cavaliers f5
savait que si on va chercher le fou je
me demandais pourquoi qui hélas est la
réponse on vous prend sa double les
pions mais du coup ça va nous donner
encore plus de cazalet droit donc ça
c'est pas vraiment dérangeant et surfe
wave 4 je sais pas pourquoi ça l'est
peut-être d'un truc qui est pas super
mais bon ça peut marcher 1 s'est déclaré
assez 4 1 ouais ou peut-on remettre
l'autre en dessin d'après reparlons a
avancé un joli cavaliers mvl là bas
quand même ça ça va clairement
bah oui mais tu heureux en tout cas
c'est après cette première défaite s'est
passé pas trop inquiétant parce que dans
le jeu j'ai l'impression que maxime est
vraiment pas en dessous il a pressé avec
les blancs avec les noirs il a réussi à
régler le premier simili problèmes qu'il
avait eu avec les noirs pardon et un bon
il a perdu la partie sur une tactique
mais globalement c'est quand même un
début de match très équilibré
ik roumaine mais mais ne domine pas il
mène au score mais il ne domine pas le
joueur français après l'arrivée on a le
temps c'est long mais c'est vrai que les
bullet font peur à bien évidemment donc
il échange une paire de tours dont on
avait un contre cela c'était comme
stratégie il qu'un risque
ycare ouest stratégie du streamer
d'aller chercher les bullet auquel
adhéreraient le fonds cmu
on avait pensé qu'en penser bah c'est
pas mal on va il garde son four et garde
sa peur de se faire embaucher 100 voilà
c'est fait donc en fait pour l'instant
car on ne fait rien je pense que pour
maxime ça va mais il garde son avantage
mental on va dire d'affaires de flou et
il espère des jours meilleurs ou à un
moment ça va s'éclaircir il pourrait
essayer
mike dean cause un nouvel échange de
tours donc simplifie donc il est dans la
commission et aux menaces
il va arriver il veut rentrer dans cette
finale meiway cette finale elle est
toujours pareil ça doit être égal mais
faut faire attention quand même une
majorité qui peut se dessiner avec les
blancs allaient l'allèle dames et y
aller de pair de fou alors après le foot
cases noires semblent pas pouvoir
attaquer grand chose pour le moment mais
le signaler en fait c'est le foot les
blonds en plus on fait dans ce rapport
au matériel garde fous cavés les comptes
de cai et fu il ya une lente mais en
tout cas ce soir en plus il est noir qui
ont deux cavaliers et donc son trois
pièces jouées sur l'autre couleur c'est
avec blanche
donc c'est un peu ça le combat des
blancs espère dominer les cases noires
des noirs espère 2014 elle sait pas vous
ou se tenir en respect les aloses les
autres ce qui est vraiment un joueur qui
est réellement mieux
dois je me disais même un cavalier c4 un
coup je peux parler de blizzard dota tu
sais pas c'est dur
moi je ne sais pas pourquoi je préfère
toujours les blancs ses positions le
d'autres à tort ou peut-être que juste
c'est égal mais qu'on pratique c'est
plus simple mais mais en fait je serais
pas trop quoi dire je comme plan pour
les blancs colas qui essaie de faire
c'est pas mal mais c'est d'échanger un
truc de d'ouvrir un petit peu les
fouilles j'aime bien quand ça sourit
mais objectivement ça va être très
compliqué vols entre eux quelque chose
mais qui ne veut faire f 6 e 5 pour
avancer un peu sa majorité à son tour de
ce côté d'elle même fait 26 d'ailleurs
enfin avoir clairement il voudra le fait
remarquer bessette pourquoi il colmate
laquelle c'est simple comme ça et pas de
calais qui viendra dessus attaqué à 6
août à 13 3 pour le blanc monté droit
web 6e 5 et on monte laurent le 6 on va
tous faire sagement blanc etc 3 norac 6
alors qu'eric a pas que le foot
peut-être un des parents a posé une
question en tout cas en quatre pour le
moment à risques à tenter un food mais
bon il y aura eu 5 1 de toute façon qui
va partir f3a emails et des tempos la
norme aimons bien ma de bajur aignan à 2
bizarrement ils vont bien échanges alors
qu'il ramenait lé font eux deux après
coup ouais c'est ce que j'ai à dire
maintenant sur cinq qui a peut-être fou
prouver 5-10 à cette fois ci à écailles
ses 5 à la fin et on ressort à copier
des cinq essais
ouais ok il veut faire faut être quatre
pour il veut faire way heureusement il
faut faire confiance mais vous c'est 120
pouces et quatre qui va venir défendre
allemand mais j'imagine il va le faire
sans frais filtre il le fait alors
quoique et c4 ou qu'ils aient baissé
kelly c4c plus offensif quand même à
première vue mais depuis on est défendu
en décembre et je sais pas je ne sais
pas je sais pas trop quoi en direct à
eséka tu peux avoir l'idée de faire ça
ici
le 5 à 25 4 encaissés 4 ce qui est
positif c'est un fou b1 b3 tout comme ça
aussi voir m
kébé cet opus était d'autres options du
coup comme vous je t'attaque des 5e et
l'appareil a pas fou cette halte obligée
mais peut-être qu'on les change quoi
même si ces convois l'axé les doigts
parce qu'il ya eu 5 quand même f 6 e 5
qui part vite et le roi qui va arriver
en d5 être faudrait il va faire food et
un j'imagine bon il ya aussi avoir accès
peut-être aurais-je devrait coûter un f6
il va commencer à avancer maxime e52
cinq probables et le rock la montre les
souris que ce qu'il aurait pas dû faire
un carré lisse et 5 en amont pour aller
se placer en b3 voir écoute il n 8
devance rennes maxime je tiens je
continue plutôt préféré un peu les
blancs mais tu vois sans savoir si son
pouvoir mieux dans ce cas-là minutes de
piste a clairement son rôle à jouer ici
peut-être un petit fouet f1 ça peut ça
peut s'auto pour aller chasser g5
constamment c'est beaucoup et ça va pas
trop mal en fait
sa faiblesse entre guillemets dessin qui
est hyper bien couverte des blancs ils
savent pas trop inscriptions pas c'est
bon il fait b3 mais c'est catherine aura
tellement de mal je n'ai pas très peur
ça va je pense
bon ça va juste être nul 1 probablement
probablement pas mal je me demande si
c'est pas si à force c'est pas maxime
qui peut symboliquement près serré on a
autre côté je vois pas comment ils
gagnent fou prend des six essais mais
bon c'est peut-être hikaru qui va devoir
commencer à penser à aller jusque vers
un nul
ce cavalier h4 c'est le cavalier mvl qui
s'installe parfois de j'imagine alors on
peut encore y avait 3 way salvateur
comme fois de la journée sa maintenant
sb3 puisse mener 5 3 des 5 sens
attention à ne pas se faire contourner
quand même c'est à cambrai le prend pas
il contourne attention attention quand
même parce que maintenant toutes les
cases d'avancé du pion son protégé mais
ça va on a quand même beaucoup de pièces
qui peut arriver mais attention la
partie la partie pourrait tourner d'un
côté ou de l'autre j'ai envie de dire
attention maxime de passer c'est pousser
le pion après tu peux tu vas te mettre
une mettre une fourchette ou un truc
avec lecavalier il fait quoi que mais
chaque camp se réunit dans secteur doit
traiter des 5 précise je croirais cette
fois-ci caroit abandonné tout espoir de
gagner la partie et les deux hommes font
nul et il reste encore 54 minutes donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya encore le temps
pour maxime de revenir dans ce cinq
oppressé faut recommencer avec la
berlinoise jusqu'à ce que ça casse en
fait la même chose qu'elle est 5e le
tournage 6 tout ça ça va recommencer
on demande c'est quoi les chiffres en
bas alors sont les cadences 1,5 plus à
1,5 me de plus une seconde parc ou 3 + 1
3000 plus une seconde par coup et un + 5
minutes plus une seconde par coup et
donc il ya le score du match en bas 2 1
en faveur du streamer américain et là il
avait joué ses 4 maxime dans la partie
précédente il avait obtenu un avantage
on peut retenter ou réfléchir à autre
chose et or des cadavres alors ça faut
ça va juste transposer s'il ya une
chance 4 il ne mangera cette fois ci
veut faire c'est 5 et 40 ou pas du tout
une tonique tattoo rico délaissé je sais
pas ça recommence et les mêmes
questionnements que la partie prémat
dans ces cinq ya pas qu'ils avaient
prévu six parce que je retiens pour un
calibre angers7
ouais donc les conditions pour eux aussi
souffrent ainsi rangé sa c5 et
progression prend 1,6
par exception prend des cats où pranger
7 talonné par exemple l'option ses 6 2
restants c6 est d'ailleurs l'effet
qu'elles existent pour faire ces 5 mai
44 l'on empêche crème sur cour j'ai ici
c'est ce qu'il veut infliger cinq
peut-être joué pour tourner un tour des
huit matchs alors pour g6 ou quoi dans
sa foulée sergent plus menacera f'tour
g6 ou g5 menace au siège 5 fab battant
rester je le sens pas ouais mais alors
tu vas où cette approche simple toucher
5 quand même mais bon je souviens c'est
la colonne des normands avec la colmater
mais je sais pas où l'essence est
d'accord c'est le cookie qui semble
briser le truc c'est qui peut la comnat
msila colmate avec food est ce un curage
et 4 h 5 immédiat qui va gagner c'est un
retour bas ils auront perdu du temps
fera le c4 peut-être puis on prend un
tour quand ces quatre familles dont il
se sera bizarre il fait qu'ali c5 en
premier qu'il engage à rien d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas ça défend de 5 également
mais avec la tour sete faciaux de le
couper donc cool
voilà bah écoutes je n'irai plus sur le
matin c'est hyper compliqué ses voisins
non mais l'aîné il est mieux il est
mieux mais ce qui est bien c'est qu'il
ya un dynamisme la position et il a les
idées en tête c'est cool c4 2e
berlinoise
oui mais oui mais oui mais un peu
délicat roi mal dès l'ouverture à vous
caro qui a dit hier qui s'était préparée
contre magnus pour la finale mais pas du
tout contre maxime donc les deux jours
les deux jours supplémentaires de
préparation ne lui ont pas permis de se
préparer mais ça ça lui a permis de se
reposer ça oui mais pas de se préparer
enfin un exploit c'est gros c'est
vraiment une grande performance hier de
maxime est clairement carlsson était
favori donc je pense que ce soit ce soit
du bluff
dans le sens où écarts ont un très
mauvais score contre magnus ouais c'est
ça et du coup il a dû dire déjà c'est
quasi sûr que magnus va gagner et quand
bien même ces maximes de toute façon
c'est mieux pour moi le jeu maxime sans
préparation que c'est sûr que du point
de vue des quarts ou c'est une aubaine
de tomber sur maxime en finale oui tant
on verra dans quelques heures mais oui
de ce pass sûr que s'ils avaient le
choix il a plutôt choisi maxime que
comme c'est un truc c'est que le head's
up le un contre un contre contre magnus
est juste et juste terrible pour hikaru
donc pour pour lui c'est le pire
adversaire pour la s qui peut tenter
d'aller mieux maxime juste sous les deux
joueurs pour cela
mais peut-être qu'il peut laisser chez 3
qui va essayer d'aller vite d'otages
biais d'objets 5 déjà posé une question
ouais pour ce les deux coups logica mais
sur à 17 pour essayer d'être tour f1 et
rentrant f77 bonbons et de redescendre à
gmac viennent mettre ces deux ouvrages
et ça ça il va essayer de jouer le bas
des attentes il va monter l'euro jusque
là n'ont en tout cas pas de phase iii
sur tourache un poisson gras je pense
que je vais pouvoir est à prévoir ouais
peut-on leroy qui montre ses rares moins
mauvaise chose
non mais c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
pour les achats d'or sa pression ça
sente pas loin de gagner en on en a deux
avantages c'est que nous on a un pur
place et qui se dessine pas les noirs et
on affronte cavaliers dans une position
sur les deux ailes donc les deux
cumulent et si on n'est pas mieux serait
étonnant qu'on avait peut être un roi
gens voient du coup une différence trop
mieux et gagnant soit pas il faut
convertir avec les mains il va tenter
ces 4 à 5 ces 5 descartes je pense déjà
sur à 5 direct et à ces quatre là c'est
ça ça je voulais faire c'est 4 noir en
chronique mais c'est un peu loin c'est 4
à 5 c 5400 fait des coûts et côté blanc
ça parte
ça peut partir en beaucoup de choses en
fait
il cessa les blancs genre d'histoire
chasseurs h4 c'est un des deux coups de
façon je sais pas lequel il va choisir
ce que roy hk est ce que roy h4 ali des
rois g53 g600 bonus peut-être mais une
fois que manger sain qui peut être nous
refaire du tout raciste du chip à quoi
nous stopper on se moque un peu pour
rien je sais pas
la rescousse bloc pour rien on risque on
s'offre l'opportunité de rentrer de
l'autre côté et par la suite il fait
tout rachat ou les durs de bon j'aurais
plutôt opté pour tous rachats mais
j'attends je sais pas voilà je calcule
pas je fais simple c'est de vue du
visuel quoi compliquer la position
est-ce que j'ai 5 h il va suffire 5 g 5
h 6 échanges et admettons est monté le
roi a mais le truc c'est quelqu'un ou
sur les seins cachés de faire celle ci
probablement pour bloquer le plus
possible qu'ils aient pas de passage
pour les pièces blanches consiste à la
difficulté donc peut-être fois faire g5
+ g63 g4 et touré fin peut-être et un
truc comme ça et se garder h6 quand on
le sent mais je pense que j'ai 5 g si
c'est mieux que j'ai 5 h 10 alors hier
par là bas ok ok il a fait un peu le
truc dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
coups de marteau tout rachat emphatique
provoquent ces 5 qui était logique pour
maintenant tu appuies c6 et la maman g5
ça peut partir si on veut il le fait
était un peu pris à droite à gauche une
principe de deux faiblesses mais alors
ce qu'il attend de faire recette roi
pachins où il fait à cinq rencontres je
l'impression à preuve le seul problème
des blancs c'est comment passer en fait
bah écoute sans feu
6 quand même des gens d'un truc g6 ou g5
échec
le roi va sur la lutte y allons pour
faire touré 27 tours effarant tout le
roi et h6 il veut plus on prend ces 3
ouais mais bon
puis on prend ces trois d'accord si on
fait j'ai 6 pi 3 bon ok je comprends
c'est trop avant tout c'est un spar a
indiqué karel et prendre des 4 x 3 à 5
tours b 3
adams mais peut-être des tours b saint
caprais mais on a quand même quelque
chose et puis on attend csat aussi pour
ses 7 qui est sympa
pour sa 7ème on coupe le roi et ses
stars mais bon ok peut-être vous
invoquez il a fait froid c'est pas bête
du tout parce que s'il prend b4 de la
tour on peut échanger faire [ __ ] en c3
qui est français de et je sais pas tu
vois je peux faire mal mais bon d'avoir
un tour un bond vers le théâtre et la
techno pion à prospérer celle cros et
puis 3 sur les victimes non plus mais ce
que six maintenant il réussit touré
chacun trois élèves s'est élargie si ce
don qui l'obligé à roissy en attendant
les six je redis je suis ceci j'ai 6 mhz
et touristes danger nature et non mais
non enfin hariri d'accord tour ici donc
il est vrai que sa fourchette mais
écoute à temps et si on prend ces trois
il prend h56 logique c'est la force
n'était pas loin on n'est pas loin
allez fab je crois que ça ait gagné ou
pas s'enflammer et chaque coach croisien
croit raymond merci quoi et sur l'échec
rhdp donc ils donnent bon bah c'est
probable en gagnant il faut gagner
il y avoue prendre trois à tanger 3g 3
c'est bon ok à l'égalisation c'est bien
marlou ted aller ça fait à ça
2 2 domine surtout surtout il le domine
vraiment avec les blancs et s'ils
règlent ces problèmes avec les noirs ça
peut il peut il peut prendre un avantage
dans ce match parce qu'il est plus
devant avec les blancs qui car ou quoi
mais tu sais que ça devrait te fous ces
quatre années dans le kernel
probablement pas forcément un an
non mais les deux ont joué elles sont
toutes dans le carnet de toute façon ah
oui tout d'accord mais je flat delajoux
est de fous ces quatre lettres carnets
le carnet le carnet rempli un ils ont
développé partie je pense qu'il est
temps de mettre un peu d kaki je pense
que c'est important
j'en vois un peu des cas qui je pense
est vraiment important la d'envoyer du
cac qui est peut-être un peu de gens
m'ont un peu de barbelés aussi du conte
à les noirs un peu de cas qu est un peu
de barbelés ça permet de j'espère qu'ils
ont envoyé des petits marlou aussi pour
pendant après la victoire mais avec les
noirs il est temps de mettre du cac et
du barbelé ça doit suffire
combien de temps il reste dans cette
section il reste pas mal de temps il
devra rester encore avec 45 minutes
trois quarts d'heure marie de ré faubert
il a changé
ils arrêtent avec son lot 5 je passais
ont changé un truc aussi mais c'est max
que je changeais étudie rockets dame c7
et la poursuite à vendredi
une petite différence cinq mamans du
coup bon j'imagine qu'il va continuer
qu'aider 5
pourquoi changer iwr par dessus le cadre
à sa sauce est juste la même chose si on
prend des cats on prend trop indécis
c'est compris ça pourrait repartir est
dans cette même position avec la paire
de joueurs pour les blancs non prendre
cinq fois ci bon du coup quad mc2 donc
la structure maintenant c'est le pion
aux 5 contre le pion au 6 qui offre un
peu d' attaque pour les blancs mais
quand tu mets le carélien f8 hublin de
bien quand même pas mal après
pas le genre de truc mais le truc c'est
que moi je vais plutôt saitoti blanc
côté noir donc je me sens plus à tirer
pour opposition blanche mais en fait on
soit alors qu'elle est roi il défend le
5 mai puis c'est tout qu'est-ce qui fait
max et 4 j'imagine est ce que tu vas
être jamais de poser la question est ce
que tu en voilà tu accoutumée pas de
calais fuite d'abord et turquoise une
question qu'est ce que tu joues bad as
me 2g mais ça peut être dame ces deux
mais j'ai plutôt eu des situations de
pièces parce que dams et 2 vient pas des
gages certes mais quand il qualifie
tonfas donc voilà il a fait dame de bon
c'était 4 à priori se faire une bonne
idée parce que tu augmentes les nombres
de questions contrôler mon fouillis
voilà il ya des cases qui peut faire b 4
après 130 c4 des blancs donc pour plein
de raisons ces quatre c'est un bon coup
dans ce genre de situation donc avec les
blancs et carreaux il va ce soit
peut-être tenté à quatre ouvrait un truc
là bas soit du cavalier h5 ou h4 au
parquet et 6,5 ou des coups comme ça un
petit peu comme dans une france est
finalement l'impact des blancs un peu
c'est ça en fait c'est en gros c'est une
française tapas d4 d5 ce qui dans
l'autre est plutôt à l'avantagé des
noirs le stijm tacaille en dessin qui
est bien placé et talent fou 17 ce qui
n'est pas bloquée et finalement les
blancs beaucoup de mal à attaquer en
fait je crois que j'ai joué sous ses 4
août maxime ans en 2002 avec un bon
résultat nul
pas mal il était petit à petit en 2002
mon signe il avait tellement j'avais 12
ans et elle était déjà fort donc les
cavaliers h5 qui part à trois nous est
pas encore donc on va voir
voir comment ils continuer ce qu'il fait
à 5 b 4 pour pour percer ce qui joue un
peu le foot cases blanches c'est ce qui
fait il a mis le carillon b6 et
peut-être il veut karelia 5 car il ya
quatre et c5 et jouer les cases
détroit et b3 où exactement
on va voir
alors comment jouer clairement j'ai
l'impression que c'est lui qui est mieux
maxime avec les noirs là enfin mieux que
c'est peut-être un grand mot mais en
tout cas il a largement égaliser
jusqu'au large leader
il a fait des trucs qu'il fallait être
bien comme il faut cho soon bonhomme
week le phosphore en b un skyblog la
tour 1 il est blanc white foil le temps
à s'organiser à se mettre en jeu ah bah
oui il était beaucoup mieux en ces deux
ans puisse y construire la casse b3
quand même ce qui peut être utile et oui
fossé d'eau serait d'ailleurs un coût
pour les blancs ici cavaliers des 4 ok
mais bon pas mal bossé centrale bloque
un peu d'autres trucs
peut-être qu'il veut faire avec 4 f 5,6
car un grand classique bon je sais pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec humour et
aussi qu'il ya des quatre lots de bonnes
choses qui fait si ce taux passe à
passagèrement mais il stoppa s'est
effectué 17 ça écrit c5 est passé par 17
du coup pour gagner un tempo sur le pion
est il par ici alors est-ce que même
cavaliers detroit 1 peut être une idée à
effet tout reprend des 4 ouf doit tempo
alors avoir surpris on prend des cats il
veut quoi et puis on prend chez his way
reprendre je suis complexe complexe
complexe complexe et goûte on prend des
quatre c'est parce que ça vaut en soi
mais il a joué tellement vite que ça
donne envie de faire confiance en tout
cas il met la pression il a réussi en
avant lors de seconde sur calais 17 mai
car ou qui évite qu'ils auront besoin
c'est parti
e il apprend que les 600 j'imagine quoi
d'autre tellement compliqué la position
après pions pranger scission pranger 6
donc c'est soit qu à deux soit le
cavalier seul et trouve du contre
intermédiaire ne sais pas trop quoi
j'aurais dû cavaler 7,1 le contre
intermédiaire mais bon mais reprend roi
va pas bien loin
le truc c'est que la tour à dole pourra
plus bouger en fait bah oui elle est
terriblement important et ben alors
attends l'idée ses pions prendra me
prend 1 et 2 et de juste jouer à y prend
des quatre intermédiaires
oui parce que tmg quatre pions prend
dame prend alors à foug c5
on est en train de se faire ma route et
là y'a 2 les mots de marloux à mon avis
qui va partir dams et 4 qui est prise
par les menaces m'attendais quand même
attention
ouais alors soit kf5 mon service c'est
bon mangez 4g si ce geste est ce que ça
va aussi aux sacrifiés à 4,1 au train de
payer 5 ha ok j'ai quatre sikhs quoi il
ya tous ces cinq où il ya des contres
d'hommes c5 d'abord web mc5 j'imagine
donc qui prend prend printemps c'est
quoi le matériel j'aime bien savoir où
j'en suis ces qualités là était de moins
mais bon bah il ya vachement de jeu par
la qualité
je sais pas qui est mieux en fait il ya
vachement de jeu j'aime bien les noirs
et va prendre du temps
la torah de leur jeu mais les rangs 1 le
four à sortir l atout revenir donc il ya
trois coups pour les blancs pour revenir
je souhaitais faut réussir à créer une
menace avec les noirs et c'est pas
simple dans quatre à cinq ans qu'il
touche fonction vous faudrait choper
influences sont champions ça va mais
comment mais c'est bizarre en fait tous
les blancs devraient être mal est en
fait tu arrives pas à percer ah oui
c'est bien joué il veut tour d2 c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien marc attend
et ce que l'autre peut faire tour à tour
d2 tour à tour de il y aura fou prend
2,3 à temps et surtout prend dame prend
et tour à mes achats alors il faut
prendre
excuse moi j'avais vu retour tour ici et
toi est ce que oui il y aura tous sont
généralement
ok le 6 si ceci tu sais pas mais paris
se passeront tout reprend tour d un tu
montres leroy non oui tour 10 et tours 2
mais peut-être dans des délais bien tour
des deux tours 2 pour dire juste la tour
en d1 sera pas comme et sibur adam
pranger de maths ou c'est très fort
c'est mais ouais tour des deux tours de
tout reprendre à prendre on apprend et
puis on procède déjà à minima tu
récupères le pion à eux et le pion g2
sûrement derrière
beaucoup viennent à une finale retour
des de hockey écologique en même temps
et qu'est ce qu'il veut faire et que son
pion à temps menacé m oui mais je veux
dire cette façon dont cette baie 4 x 4
faut prendre trois échecs et on prend à
deux tours 8
trois points f7 ouais c'est gagné et ben
voilà le streamer américaine sueur voilà
je veux un peu de bardot est un peu de
marleau et b ap un peu de brp quand même
ici il faut du marleau et dubé ap je
pense aller j'en envoie ça c'est grâce
aux barbelés qui ont été mis un très
important ça et quand on commence à
mettre les émaux de ça le match tourne
complètement savoir je vois ça chez moi
y'a du pap il ya le député ouais c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien ce qu'ils
font varier un peu de pépé la fia du 200
g
allez on prend le lead enfin dans ce
match fab avec des belles parties laddh
maximum en femme pour prendre quatre
c'est super ah bah ils au dessus
ils jouent ils jouent beaucoup mieux que
qui car ou en ce début de match est ok
il y avait partout une berlinoise
ou pourquoi pas l'italien et le roda
3150 qui se matérialise un petit à petit
ou 3116 ce soir il a trouvé le bon
adversaire pour un il a peut-être trouvé
le client le client américain
c'est bien joué maka qui dansent pas ce
soir il fait pas de grimaces rien il est
hyper concentré c'est rarissime al elle
a compris qu'il est tombé sur sur fauré
oui les sorties il a changé de il a
changé de plan de jeu a lancé maxime qui
a fait pousser 4 oui pourquoi est ce
qu'il est pas retourné sur la berlinoise
jeu après comme ont discuté hier avec
baky parfois il peut y avoir des manques
de lucidité dans ces matches où les
parties sont très tendues tu n'as pas le
temps de souffler j'aimerais aller y
avait peut-être une raison ici
concrètement mais parfois ça peut juste
être un manque de lucidité dans votre
façon
maxime il alterne entre spe d'alitalia
oui mais juste les berlinois se sont
tellement bien passé jusque là pour
l'instant je devrais peut-être qu'il a
décidé aussi d'ouvrir une carte c'est à
dire qu'il sait que la berline on a un
ça va
il veut voir un petit alien pour
préparer l'italienne normes pour le 3 +
1 tu vois ouvrir une carte pour pour le
pour la suite du match pour pouvoir
checker 8 son côté le l'italienne
d'hikaru est allé le toit lui ouvrir de
cartes dans la gueule quoi lui dire si
tu enfin si tu règle le problème de la
berlinoise je vais revenir sur
l'italienne et je saurai quoi faire
anderson ouais ça peut être aussi pour
ouvrir une carte supplémentaire à ce que
des musiques y être opérée il ya une
super position n'a encore ouais j'aime
bien tout le temps enfin retourner
stream et pour les quarts ou peut-être
si fous ces deux bons gros ce qu'il
aimerait arrêter blanc ses 85 ans mais
même ici c'est parce que là bas si f4 f5
la crise est finie toi mon peignoir faut
savoir paris sa et dont quelques
poussées de il enlève le blocus
potentiel en est simple donc ça c'est
cool
et voilà qu'on soit problématique de
carreaux de solutionner prise d'antenne
dès cet été au complet nous apparaît sur
les quatre et n'auront droit qu'à elle
de faire du g6 des jeux comme ça
f5 même aux mavs voilà les cinq eux
mêmes mais 5e même un tapis ont passé
protégé après mais bon ramé qui là aussi
après il est pas si loin
tu manges ici sur la fuite mais bon ça
prend un peu de temps ok à 4 j'aime bien
pour plein de raisons tu bloques les
noirs et puis ta tour à trois jours pour
aller en b3 pour la f3 pour manger 3
pour aller dans deux saisons
sais tu qui dit avec batterie qu bruel
comme entraîneur pas étonnant que mv
l'on voit c'est à wade kart wii
important patrick bruel d'antoura trois
parties ça coulisses ces couvre le donc
les normes comptables c'est un petit
bouquin de tourbe et 3 par manque
attaque le fou qui vise 17
même si c'est vrai il peut il prendre la
solution radicale ne veut pas laisser un
je pense qu'il a raison tu peux pas
laisser cette menace latente chez vous
c'est trop grave c'est arrivé donc tour
b3 il attaque le fou au passage
attention à pions prend 1,5 to reprend
b6 puis on prend des 4 mai à foug d2 ça
va ça peut être les idées de marloux de
du joueur américain à la ça fonctionne
pas mais c'est le genre de truc qu'il
aime bien faire ça et après danser un
peu écoute si on le voit pas danser ce
soir sera bon signe si on va pas manger
de salade dans ses allées cela dit
l'arrêté non il peut reprendre à tout
moment
non il y manger entre les parties on
connaît pas sa recette
ce qui est du poulet tous à césar nous
américains il aime bien du coup il a
fait pions 3 et 6
là encore faire gaffe ou prendre et
quatre intermédiaires il y en a beaucoup
et elle avait beaucoup d'options en mai
4 était intéressant d'ailleurs
est ce qu'on va leur claquer une qualité
prend des quatre ans il 3.6 j'imagine
après je sais pas la suite mais est-ce
que cavalli h5 et au rejet 3 il a fait
tout un foin f6 je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'ici on est un peu sorti
carulla alors pour l'instant oui mais
bon on va voir ce que tu as quand même
ce pion des cartes qui restent faibles
avec l'ail peut me prendre au prochain
coup oui qu'il faut que d'autres on va
juste d'amener de un ou des chats
parties ont débattu à moi je leur dis de
progrès à cinq pro passage mais oui
pourquoi pas dire moi je voulais aller
là bas mais oui voyage dans ses trains
alors d2 il ya un truc je n'ai pas trop
c'est que toi kf3 c'est trop un truc qui
peut arriver dans les tranchées
peut-être qu'on sait trop où ils
pouvaient regarder dans les prochains
jours kiev 3 qui a aidé degré des trucs
comme ça reste
ok bon site aveux de secret story 3 on a
pris beaucoup de temps bonheur b3 et on
se rend compte ce papa ni veut revenir à
heppenheim à la strada prend 1,5 au
passage que pour le monde sur d'un point
à 5 il faut prendre des quatre qui joue
sur le clouage avec la tour 1 la tour
sera protégé qui récupère un tempo à ce
moment là mais ce que j'avais demandé
screener on va faire flamber 8 pour
prendre le g2 bras et faire cuire et f5
vannes aux cookies qui me posent des
questions c'est 5 des nombres alors toi
ce qu'il peut aller prendre en g3
pourquoi pas avec eux qu'ils
reviendraient vers ou quatre élèves ce1
qui toucheraient des trucs après il
repartirait comme ça un peu il l'a pas
fait car où il n'a pas fallu mais sa
batterie s'échauffe ce qu'est l'e3 plus
ou moins mobilisé bon ce sera parce que
ça ferait barrage de dames g2l rival en
f1 mais bon il y aurait carré des f-5 à
ce moment là ouais ou des tours j'ai six
ou des fous comment commence à la carte
italienne qui va peut-être vitres être
refermé un par le joueur français des
valeurs maintenant
voilà c'est quel point on est maintenant
de retour prêt tu vas faire ton prend
aussi ce tour là tu protèges la écoute
et tu menaces entre guillemets tour en
cavalier prend pour égaler fin pour
égaliser mais pour égaliser jugement
écoutent salaire est ce que ton g65 d'un
match devant fnaeg de roi ici d'un
mi-temps 16-3 c'est l'heure d'aller à
l'heure d'aller donc non pas pour g6 il
a pris donc peut prendre aussi 100
premiers ou prendre ainsi vrai ça change
pas grand chose au final
ah non il a raison c'est un sens par ok
donc il joue le petit avantage mais
est-ce que ça suffit ça pour les morts
le fou va venir en aide deux mais ça va
être chiant quand même parce que c'est
un vrai pas assez sur le fond rien ses
pions là mais il a toujours la stratégie
de jouer dit maxime ce thème vient il de
se prendre la pression terrible autant
ski cas où va compter dessus là pour
gagner c'est parti c'est pas si simple
pour lui de progresser il va faire un
bep 6 et 5 tout ça inscriptions mais si
en plus tu es mieux autant forcément
c'est d'autant plus dur donc là faut
sortir les barbelés un faut mettre un
maximum de barbelés alors tu peux le
panaché avec quelque chose pour le
rendre plus puissant
donc il ya une mûre deux heures volées
avec ce que de la fusée la fusée ou du
kaki à voir mais le cac est puissant
quand même hein il fait dames 6 g 4
arrivera même ça je pense qu'il va la
tenir quand même surtout avec les kakis
que je vois là qui partent savons ces
sorciers qui met les cas qui sont entrés
ration il ya des petites raya des roses
il ya des messages d'amour pour pour
hikaru à est dans les roses les
ressources darryl carreaux qui fait un
peu des signes de tête des 2 déception
il a vu les cas qui a été terrible fini
les 220 mille boîtes ou non là c'est
terrible pour lui le sel qui part aussi
pour hikaru ses terres il pourrit garou
beaucoup trop des modes contre lui il ne
peut rien faire
ayad et 200 grammes ya des pleutres
j'espère qu'ils étaient en train de
prendre des petites photos là important
des beaux murs comme ça mais bon allez
on tenu des parts de ge ont tenu et on
repart d'assister à la caisse
ces quatre nouvelles cartes dans son
niveau il ne s'est pas préparée contre
le bon joueur il n'a pas senti fort du
jour france ouais bah qui nous met
beiteinou est un peu des roses avec les
barbelés aussi voilà ça c'est puissant
ouais ça a l'air très puissant du coup
assez pour cette partie là encore je
pense qu'il faut encore du du barbelé
rosé malchance qui prend des petites
photos l'a été il doit être content de
voir ses murs assez des beaux murs un
commandement voir plus souvent
bah oui c'est ils font plaisir cela il
ya des petits marlou ans qui
apparaissent tu vois quand même mais les
marlous c'est pour les victoires plutôt
ça après une victoire
bon là c'est un peu nul devant l'ot du
bas qui est quand même qui par aussi tu
as et ses complexes là il est complexe
le mur difficile à comprendre le mur
n'est pas n'est pas homogène
trop de choses qui se passent dans ce
match mais les ouvertures qui se passe à
ça et encore une nouvelle structure
structure espagnole
mais le temps de verser 4 et le cavalier
pour revenir en c5 donc c'est une sorte
de briord gens ne te dire la structure
mais quand on a quelques temps de
boisson alors que kei c6 qui avait huit
qui et 17 c en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque fois il transpose en une
structure qui ressent le espagnoles
françaises ou quoi mais c'est tout temps
des bonnes mains des bonnes versions une
bonne façon d'espagnol une bonne version
2 française
ça a l'air plutôt agréable à voir ici à
faire pression ça surtout avec maxime et
il connaît tout ça quand on sait et
c'est excellent en fait avec les
vengeurs de variantes contre des joueurs
moins expérimentés et même jusqu'à 2000
jusqu'à 26
60 par exemple mais même 60 hertz plus
diffus partir de 62 ça devient vraiment
dur vraiment très très bien
jusqu'à 61 oui donc car alliage de
l'écouté veut rejouer l'écart et j'ai
quattro où il veut jouer un rêve pas
trop bon moi je savais que c'est plus
pour faire des rêves 3 kg 4 ou h 4 h 5
des trucs comme ça mais parce que s 4 le
problème en fait c'est quand tu es noir
échange ça donne comme la caisse de cinq
pompiers vallier est
et on fouille peut être pas mal mais bon
après y'a combat cessa que le fourbe et
s'adjuge mc tapiès c'est pas trop fier
avec les noirs parce que il a rien à
faire là donc efficacité pris un peu de
vitesse de l'autre côté tu peux vite se
faire attaquer il faut voir d'ailleurs
une nouvelle a gagné lui même une bonne
partie un peu avec ça contre une baisse
âme en top12 ya un an ya deux ans fin au
dernier top 12 mais du coup il ya eu
quasiment deux ans maintenant
ok il blindes n'est pas mécontent ainsi
toute la semaine ensemble et j'ai quatre
tâches qu'attache fin qui va partir
écouteurs bon f4 ça reste une option
pour les blancs à un moment ou un autre
je veux dire ce tableau donnait la case
au 5e une catcheuse
parce que si un échange de gagnac sd4
aussi c'est toujours pareil quand les
chèques qui me tue
tu donnes quelque chose tu gagnes autre
chose à faire un choix tu peux pas tout
avoir
bah c'est le rêve de tout avoir mais en
général c'est à dire ça je suis pas trop
mal tu auras pas tout donc pour le
compte des adversaires faible c'est ce
que tu n'as tu fais des carpes au fond
du coeur des trucs comme ça c'est bon
quoi faut faire gaffe à des fous pranger
c'est trois projets cette dame h ici ça
me fait peur ou mais là j'ai maintenant
l'impression de max bons écoutants voir
l'âge 5 6 fait j'ai cinq pieds carrés
des f-5 j'ai l'impression qu'ils g50
après que ça ouais mais tours b 8 c'est
bien il veut pousser 8 il veut revenir
avec le vrai ce fouillis manque
tellement à la défense il est pas bien
bessat temps des stages
alors il a pris on comprend
vraisemblablement ils échangent
maintenant la sueur du blâme un jardin
magique at on a doublé la matanza l'air
d'être un g7 et heureusement qu'il n'a
pas tout rachat après des travaux rue du
km5 sa cuisse de pièces bon pour pour
faire peur et je sais pas ce que ça
donne peut-être rien du tout mais c'est
un truc toujours aussi qui peut être la
tendance est positive je te rassure toi
je te rassure ça nous fait pas peur pour
moi mais pas précisé prépare avec du
tour 3 peut-être je pense tous ses buts
ses clips sont pas bêtes salut calculer
mais je veux dire là ça se regarde pas
quelle idée ça peut être car élèves 5
puis on prend d'un match 6 3 g 8 qui est
pour le 5 ou damage 6 first 3g 8,5 à ce
que je sais pas dans quel sens pourquoi
pas commencer par 4 5 vous tuer chaque
quand même bah non je suis ressorti on
prend pions prend et qui s est peut-être
quelque chose je suis tout aussi valérie
six mois ou pas ça pue flybuy à du
cavalier piscine cros qui arrive
bon faut des barbus faut beaucoup de
barbus c'est la première qui se passe
vraiment mal en vrai okello de la
qualité c'est sûrement le meilleur choix
pratique est clairement veut dire ça se
passe mal mais on n'a pas encore perdu
elle est complexe celle là il faut
peut-être en profiter aux outils
performants et position comme ça pour
récupérer côté maxime tu sais des fois
quand ça se passe mal
essayez tenter un truc pratique et en
profiter pour reprendre ses esprits et
pour être d'attaqué dès le début de la
prochaine
ce cadre permet de jouer parce qu'il le
feu moment il ya patrick bien sûr aux 5
ce qui a repoussé pour fermer prendre
l'espace
c'est une jcct mais après je vois les
colonnes permet du coup tu fermes pas
grand chose et c'est chaud si je suis
vraiment heureux sont difficiles il faut
peut-être accepté de fermer essayé de la
jouer un maximum de coups en tentant des
petits pièges et puis et puis repartir
de plus belle dans la prochaine
je prendrai mais bon je crois que non
mais c'est sûr que tout perdre à cesser
la question entre cas quel truc obtient
pur présent mais là je crois que le
problème c'est que ça rentre en a sept
en plus âpre a engrangé 3,7 et le fou il
peut aller en d1 et tous revenir quelque
part mais je crois que ça rende vraiment
partout en fait maximale des draizes
parti s'est mal passé on va dire sur
cette ronde est assis c'est lui qui a
changé
ok donc 18 46 rs 2 parties normalement
fait partie accrochée 1 qui vont souvent
jusqu'au bout il serait bien de gagner
un ennemi en 2000 à la fin du truc
exactement exactement
ok même s'il ya un partout c'est pas si
mal vu le contenu
[Musique]
maxime domine un bon jeu sans fin je dis
pas on s'en tire bien je veux dire on
est bien dans le match 3 ouais mais bon
ce qui inquiète c'est qu'il ya le bullet
après faut prendre des points la femme
on va pas se contenter d'un parc ou là
allez on va essayer de chercher chercher
mieux ah ouais bah j'aimerais bien faut
qu'on prenne le lit de la fin de ce 5 +
1 sa saison puisque si on peut prendre
plus ça maintenant et +13 plus ça en
fait on arrive à plus de quoi faut
prendre il faut prendre ce qu'on peut
prendre
alors est-ce que h3k idée simple parce
que ça vaut quelques années où le bullet
fait peur hein frappe quand même bien le
dire car il veut faire bouger 5 max un
jeu wii ce projet
il veut envoyer le fou g5 et sans
prendre ben c'est pas mal la tuque loup
tu peux être planté un f6 tu peux faire
plusieurs choses sont enfin le sang et
jusqu'à date des deux tours c'est enfin
papa juste beaucoup mieux là non bah
faut faire bouger qu'il faut g4 ces deux
coups aux thématiques non pour essayer
d'attaquer des quatre mes choix confuse
et simple c'est même tout proche 3 mgf
tu vois ce que ça va bloquer la pêche
6.8 et non bonne nouvelle pour les non
h3 il empêche fou g4 maintenant alors
qu'elle est les machins moi je ne pas
semer s'en sortir une soupe a préféré le
garder mes potes on peut aller plus vite
ok il a fait comme ça ces saintes
donc ça parce que je suis un peu de
bennani sion pouces mais on n'est pas
tenu de pousser tel detroit ont tous
fondé deux fois le 3 mai il y aura cassé
donc ça on peut pas vraiment être donc
peut-être des trois fois f4 d'accord il
veut mettre la pression sur sur des six
courts délais qui tient son truc mais
quaden c1
il ya toujours là aussi il ya dames
c'est un peut-être déjà maintenant alors
peut-être sur fou prend il veut à ce
qu'ils voudraient pas mais les chances
meka et c4 et b3 mais je crois tu veux
repartir ailleurs il va pas il était
trop traumatisés par un ca des foulées
de fou prend ainsi soin fait ça les
énormes avantages d'un croc h6 c'est que
dès que ce fou de kasma repas on a pu
ainsi c'est beaucoup plus mal quand j
aime ce qu'il tombe et du coup ça fait
vivre vraiment encore plus le roi noir
ouais ouais ma position est très
complexe à toi tu as 2
soit tu fais ces captures ont passé soit
tu fais b4 et puis elle peut les verbes
et cinq états des belles cases ans et
trois des quatre jambes et 4500 clarté
compte en effet notre site assez de
coups il n'y a pas de faits à 5 à 4 août
à tour à 8
bon après qu'ils aient blanc tantôt lui
tendant un mot puisque dame des deux
attaques là bas une tour en 1 25 au
centre comme aussi des trucs quoi donc
c'est compliqué à mettre qui veut
envoyer des mares louer des cas qui
allait terminer de 5
qui va partir
ça joue ça veut dire il n'y a pas une
voir une partie où il ya des du répit ça
envoie ça s'est compliqué chaque fois 5
intérêts sanctions problème 5 kg qu'est
ce qui lui prend à ces jeux c'est ce à
quoi un moment probablement comment
régler le souci quatre jours cette
tribune à cazaux 6 mais en fait je suis
pas trop foot caisse blanche et a pas de
place pour y aller étape atias royal est
quoi l accès complexe après 5 tu vois tu
comprends je suis fou prend sur
cavaliers de france et deux bons pour
prendre ces deux prénoms d'emprunt
quatre d'entre eux gagnent c'est
exactement ce que je vois ça tu regardes
quoi regarder d'un air sets 5-7 fous ces
deux tours c2c ça allez mesdames f7 et
là je me demandais si on va pas se
retrouver mal enfin david o dames 2e
tour à cette rue que ouais où il ya des
cinq aux siens qui sait en l'air après
ce que tu peux le prendre pour l'instant
je ne sais pas faut faire le plan des
cinq sacs c'est un problème c'est un peu
tout seul j'ai peur d'un d'un fouet f5
tour 17 blindage et après la perte du
fou qui parlent ce qui va être beau les
deux dames 2 de comportement il ya
toujours un peut-être juste mêmes foot
pro b 6
non ça ça va sur fouet fuite ça va
fouler cette à tour cette année des
saints qui défend mais ok là pour
détruire sacrifices sur un jour c'est
sûr partout où je ne suis pas dérangé
c'est trois proches de saddam hussein
contre cette coupe revanche si ce projet
dit dame repart chez eux ou moi des fois
on se fait chier mais ok ça marche pas
ça marche pas donc je n'y fais ça barry
menace tour 7 maintenant on vous prend
2,5 à 3,3 g prend fin j'apprends j'avais
beau théâtre bbc je crois que six façons
c'est une gaffe boxing after foot gay
qui attend s'est pas perdue terme de 3,6
à récupérer quelque chose
l'option des six manon j'espérais que
qu'1 dame si ce machin c'est un rebond
sur le fou mais saâdane qui a trois fois
5 kg 4 il n'ya pas g5 petit petit petit
exploit
ouais mais on va être quand même trop
loin il va faire franges et 4 et des 5
et 4 c'est déjà beau jeu tu feras fou
voire experts leur nom mais avec des 5
des cas de cession ou des 5 6 4
mais bon allez
[Musique]
alors on sait pas encore on n'est pas
bien c'est bien joli et fo prend ses
cinq tours ces huit fautes 3 le retour
fo ces deux annonces et kata tu te crois
la marée des pions sont trop forts c'est
purement ressentant byte entre vaccins
une raison et la logique est pas mal
mais bon ça pourrait vite ou je sais pas
quoi
problème il ya plus de vingt quatre
échecs
dommage d'être mené ben ouais c'est
super mal payés pas je dire sur cette
partie là et regardez dit rick haworth
au mieux je trouve mais tu vas le payer
c'est d'être derrière au score parce que
il pas bon être parent c'est loin d'être
fini
j'en ai même pas vie match de hockey
alors il nous fait des tricks l'iran
c'est une variante triki ça il veut
planter des pièges à base d'oeuf ou les
cinq échecs et les problèmes sur rêve
cet etf ou g5 qui cloué foulée 5 de
l'autre côté etc
c'est clair qu'il faut pour cela tu veux
faire enfin il veut faire des fous prend
des stades tu vois que j'ai un grand du
cavalier et si tu reprends du foot u par
bessat est et tout ça c'est ça c'est un
peu c'est pas si simple et la fois ci ce
nom c'est qatar mais c'est possible sur
quoi être fier c'est des trucs ou méheut
peut-être que j'ai
si c'est pas ou peut-être faut faire
crisser 6-2 var qui l'obligé pas aux
coups 4 bon ça vachement c'est un
moindre mal de perdre le pion
honnêtement
c'est quand même pas terrible mais le
foie justice ça faisait vraiment mal ça
va c'est fou g7 aussi l'adoption de
moins mais toutes actives quoi laisser
peut-être dans le style de maxime
en fait c'est parce que c'est vraiment
le scénario inverse j'ai l'impression du
match d'hier
après c'est ainsi qu'on va pas garder la
paix lors de fouilles longtemps ouais le
fou en plus il serait en g7 il rit
donnerait du contre je mets en recette
est vraiment mal placé quoi alors voilà
c'est juste que le père soit et kata et
il faut retenir une nulle haifa moins
deux ce serait vraiment un chien est
loin de ces beaux coins se serait pas
terminé terminée mais c'est beaucoup
plus à faire cavalier à troyes où kenny
2e revers 6 4 il ya des belles 4 ces
pièces enfin on n'a pas vraiment
apparemment de jeu qu'on sait tout sur
tout on fait de l'option qui manque au
delà du pion qui manque c'est la case c4
en fait que tu perds par la case et du
coup tu as et 5 aces au fragile
tu accumules quoi ouais
il protège la dame
il n'y a pas de calais c4 qui est
français quatre fours f4 de cette façon
et 1,5 kg a pas de problème de clouage
bombes et roquettes tout faire foi de 6
soit retouchée mais bon ça peut aller
ok pas mal ça aurait pas d'autres
peuvent être leurs des quatre verbes et
quatre vingt dix cases même s'il vient
les captures noir ou encore bon problème
quelle équipe parce qu'il faut être
quatre donc on veut pas partir si vite
et peut-être les blancs dans le temps de
s'organiser tordez cette affaire qu'on
fout des deux fours de 3,6 24,3 en b2
tout-va a probablement toi je sais pas
où ils vont aller couper deux peut-être
pas logis bonne diagonale est bien placé
et puis tout y est
après un e3 je peux dire soit mal un
tuteur d'année sur ces 5
c'est probablement un des deux façons
c'est plus en plus pour pour hikaru
c'est sûr que c'est gagnant après après
faut convertir
c'est à dire que c'est pas si simple
mais chez page sur impressionné quoi
parle par son côté clic à 3 ok il ne
voulait pas que le cahier en b 4 kg
lançant des attaques et ces deux et
défend comme ça que tu auras deux donc
c'est passif mais il estime que l'udc et
n'auront pas d'autres menaces il a le
temps de se mettre en place de
conseillers dans un premier temps pour
repousser petit à petit des personnes
max on n'arrive pas à écrire menace avec
les noirs en fait ils moi il me manque
vraiment une option b en fait pas le
pion qui manque qui change vraiment toi
la sas doivent là on voit vraiment pour
les voir plus débutants l'importance
d'avoir un pion plus sas c'est une pièce
offensive en fait qui manquent
réellement maxime tente un jeu allèles
dame qui l'aurait probablement pas tenté
s'il avait un pion b ou en tout cas pas
comme ça
ok donc il prend de quoi on prend du
plomb de la tendance pour ne garder
champions pour un peu trop rester à la
masse de cheveux blancs il veut il veut
essayer de faire de tenir le 2 contre 4
quoi pardon ça c'est moi qui ai dit ce
projet la pièce ailleurs avec sa tour
qui tend à deux impôts quoi ou cliquer
et qui n'ont pas fermé la maligne mais
un peu mieux que le 7 tours le tour un
qui va arriver assez intéressante ou
comment cas où ils essayent de conclure
cette partie où construit beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup avant de passer à
autre chose et c'est souvent des choses
il faut faire une photo et pris un
premier avantage de tout mettre en place
avant de passer à une étape de dents
dans l'évolution de la position cercle
après ce temps il souhaite pas d'être
poussé ses pions pour faire une nouvelle
dame
il a en tête de pia avant quelques coups
mais c'est pas encore le moment et puis
on va voir maxime pour l'instant il
s'accroche à la fois cette course et 500
des 4 qui voit la c3 constant peut pas
si sûr c'est une belle position pour les
bons mais ils dépendent trop bien maxime
pour le moment après après le chaos
comme tu disais 1 il a pas encore tenter
de la gagner va peut-être commencer
maintenant à faire j'ai quatre avec dire
f3 qui avaient des f-5 il va commencer à
aller chercher le deuxième avantage ce
que maxime le la concession qu'il a fait
pour bloquer les pions c'est tout mettre
sur noir oui
du coup la foutrait mauvais mais au
moins qui défend ses pions tours 4 ouais
ça va rendre avec l'eau depuis elle va
rendre à 4,4 du tour ces quatre là ça
commence à faire et il est quasiment son
problème
sinon on les défend pas du tout est
blanc joue que sur les quais second tour
à quatre probables tour à tour 4 l'autre
et senna rangée de coulissage là
qu'était manger après le strict bien
qu'il a réussi à faire ce qu'il ya 15000
pions h4 donc ce lecavalier le tas pas
grand chose donc qui blindent un peu
maxime et ça va normalement c'est jamais
suffisant c'est comme entre 3 minutes 30
il en restera peut-être encore une
dernière
on va voir poids à ses chances il ya des
trucs comme ça qu'ils passent donc ils
échangent
donc il ya toujours qu un pion cusm et
ça ouvre de nouvelles faiblesses avec g5
qui arriverait là il va bientôt en avoir
deux essais terminés un g5 ou g5 savoir
de faire malgré cette fois abandonné et
puis c'est de gagner de revenir à un
point
ce que va faire maxime passage à vide un
côté français l'aï mené d'un point et il
vient d'encaisser trois défaites
consécutives
fab ouais c'est que je suis innocent je
veux dire si le niveau de jeu était
vraiment là au début on serait plutôt
dominateurs ils là que ce soit facile
d'accès 4g qui ressemble à une brière
jeune espagnol ce soit l'autre sp mg6
avant et cette partie là bas et ici j'ai
trouvé l'ouverture en fait il a fait
justice un coup trop cool et aux 5es
compagnie c'était vraiment l'impression
c'est plus que content mais contrit car
on a déjà vu un des matchs de maxime on
a déjà commenté 2-1 de speechless ça
souvent été un peu ce scénario là on
sent maximum de matches bien ou quoi et
tout d'un coup ils en perdent et trois
quatre cinq d'affilée après il recrée
aéré réalisé entre guillemets mais du
coup ce retard de 3 4 5 points qui
prenait bien rester jusqu'au bout quoi
et ça ne le faudrait
la gagner c'est hyper important ouais
c'est la peau vraiment là pour nous ça
la fout vraiment la gagner on envoie des
roses dont on voit tout en tout cas il a
changé de système il a joué 8 h45
alliance et 3 s'était passé trois
décades
non seulement il peut ramener ce qui aux
yeux de vergers 3faire h5 faire le trou
chez son adversaire pour enfants pour
s'engouffrer 5 way
il ya des roses qui partent
il ya des cas qui est un peu tout et il
ya du cahier j'ai trois quarts et les
f-5 d'un script pas des dessins pour en
france
c'est la question que vous posez avec
l'étranger quatre genres qui est prend
b3 et dessins ou des cinq secondes de
sens et on va voir ce que ça fait qu'à
liège de direct parce qu'il a donc
défendu son tueur attaquer mais ça fait
pas maintenant la finale fin peur aux
gens c'est bon c'est vrai qu'il a un
talent fou g7 on a le trou est incomplet
leurs deux coups en échange le tronc f4
il va peut-être plus de mal à venir même
il pourra s'échanger contre oui bon à
prendre
je sais pas auquel cas où qui pousse
tous partout c'est vrai qu'il a raison
ce type ouvert le centre alors que les
vents sont compromis en poussant et bien
sûr une aile c'est plutôt pas idiot ce
qui nous fait part il ya toujours le
pion prend puis on prend car il prend en
premier
et puis on prend puis on prend dame
prend des buts où il menace puis on
prend qui comprend d'apprendre à prendre
vous trompez 3 ces deux dates mais sinon
il a raison pas fixé le centre mais se
gardent les autres en de faire 6 4 de
faire des cadres de faire des cadres de
faire je sais pas quoi faire sans que
c'est une catastrophe pour les blancs
vrai que ça se vendait le carélien f5
qui fait rien et bien mais oui en fait
il est seul
ça leur fait il est fort mais il est
sale surtout
il ya un autre cavalier en soutien ces
quatre fait mal un truc qui avait laissé
six il ramène du monde encore je ne sais
pas le jouer mais si je suis en c4 le
plus logique de tous ces maximes réussi
à tenir après les pas perdus quand même
non plus parce que pour le moment les
pièces hikaru certes sont bien placés
mais il n'y a pas de menace dans le
rough ou prof ou des trois saints
problème d'être un problème
il prend 25 ans qu'on peut admirer en
fait c'est pour éviter que les karellis
soli et ça évite messieurs maintenant il
va ramener il va essayer de ramener son
fou mais attend peut-être que maxime
l'un tient quand même bon c'est pas
perdu c'est pas perdu c'est juste ça me
reste est très bon mais il faut faire
quoi d'amd de b3 infoterra gazière
j'imagine bond à 5 peut-être fini à 5 à
4 à l'écart est de 3 cas des cinq fois
essayez vous et 3 et se placer c'est
compliqué complexe
ouais maxime qui a un petit passage à
vide là vraiment prêt serait qu'il a
joué hier le match contre contre magnus
qui paye aussi un peu physiquement c'est
à ta les deux faces de telles émotions
la fatigue et aussi mon mental et
physique parce que vont céder mon match
et tu souffles entre les parties c'est
assez chiant c'est pour ça que je dis
est ce qu'ils payent et ce qu'ils payent
aussi un petit peu l'exploit d'hier ça
s'est souvent vu sa balle genre tu joues
les all blacks en demie tu gagnes mais
au final tu joues tu pas à les charlots
quoi tu te prends camus l'australie où
un gros truc qui me suit la faute à quoi
ouais compliqué je suis absente être
encore même plus fort tu fous mais c'est
ça tu peux tu peux tu peux payer parfois
aller les gros matches quand même ça
peut être compliqué cette dame ont
poussé jamais rien et quand tu commences
à même voir que d'un truc comme fou
prend 1,4 peut marcher non je pense pas
que tu joues mais j'ai quand même fou
prend 1,4 peut marcher faye a repoussé
cinq qui donne envie pour les noirs
aussi pour gagner la casse des deux
ouais c'est ce qui fait c'est plus
logique ce que tu es tu es assez fou
prend 1,3
c'est dur ça la fout est-ce que je peux
troll un gars qui dit qu'on cherche des
excuses pour dire que maxime est moins
vérifiables
je fais un petit rôle pour 7 300 qui
pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils caro est
plus fort que maxime rendez vous aux
candidats en mars prochain
on verra si cars ou fini devant ou pas
c'est pas fixer le temps est le plus
important de l'année 2021 fab
on pense que maxime finira devant quand
même un très bon a priori
a priori on verra on verra comme ça et
là on sera bien sûr de lucky de calais
plus fort des deux on en reparle dans
trois mois je suis ici j'ai l'impression
qu'il va le regarder sur sa chaîne
twitch un des candidats mais moi j'étais
obligé d'envoyer un petit troll mon fab
je me suis fait plaisir à ips ou les
trous dans le tchat
je vais non mais car oui il est très
fort non mais c'est sûr mais ce n'est
pas une oubliée donc j'ai trop délaissé
ses mérites du tout mais la
programmation ça reste aussi un sujet
qui se passe dans ce match quoi qu'il en
soit ré c'est normal qu'un joueur puisse
s'opposer deux jours où il se prépare et
trois jours est carrément net se mettre
sur la tronche la veille à moins de
vingt quatre heures du truc bon allez
c'est pas maxime il va remonter
il va remontrer pas écoute soutien
salaires déjà parce que là bon en fait
j'ai mieux à coup sûr maintenant qu'il
ya quelqu'un quelque un scoop bien oui
il la tient il la tient après on est
toujours au top un cercueil noir sont
bien installés à colonne des biens
blindés latourelle joue pas tous à la
dame virtuel est là juste défendre b2
donc c'est pas dit que ça tienne mais je
sais plus de chance maintenant que ce
qu'on avait tout à l'heure voilà
maintenant est ce que maintenant le
problème si je pensais car il prend
prisé temps points 4 dames des deux
dames g1 ils repassent par f 4 mois il
faut la défendre mais les barbelés de
partout dan des deux probablement un et
au rejet de damas dame prend b2 am et
adam prendrait mais qu'elle prend 1,5
oulala de me dire c'est tellement peur
mesdames d'un j'aime bien mais bon
l'essentiel 30 b2 oui mais tu prend 1,5
quand même 2 attendu fèves sinon tu fais
f6 peut-être fab où tout autour des 8 et
non attends ali la gagne qui la gagnent
dégainent tiède c'est extraordinaire
j'aime tant désiré à ce jeu je vois pas
comment fait ça fais moi confiance il va
arriver à trouver un truc de marloux un
cavalier f6 il a trouvé quelque chose
allait passer devant ces moments des
trois roues dans le jdd et en tant que
ça donne envie de trouver quelque chose
là quand même
il prend aussi 5
[Musique]
parce que déjà juste à 3,5 à roues qui
propose nul il propose le way
mais attends attends attends tintin fav
maxime qui refusent ces travailleurs bah
ouais mais attend il est peut-être mal
puisque juste il va faire cinq api 6 et
ça devrait aller mon maxime labarre life
outre ils arnaquent jusqu'au bout à la
proposition de marloux allée f 6 échecs
intermédiaires je pense vous fouleront
alaba en crawl sion ont fait eux 6 on
lui on lui laisse son pion de merde mais
il peut donner mes trades à maintenant
ouais mais ça faisait gagner un temps où
est ce qu'on s'en fout on monte on s'en
fout roy g2 il va pour tours troyes
j'imagine pour prendre 25 éprise de
recettes
c'est pas si simple nom va pas la gagner
mais limoges juste wrap tempête de
tourcoing de ctv pinguet temps je mets
juste ici non non je vais juste vérifier
ok battant c'est pas mal at entourent g7
il ya de ça poursuit roi et fit ya eu 7
et tourgéville ont à chaque il va
falloir bomber bout de 120 morts juste -
juste - il fallait il fallait il fallait
le troll un tout d'un coup hikaru la
sarre à saturer ça fait du bien bayfiles
au défi la fusée était partie à sa
mérite d'envoyer des fusées l'allant le
chat ça va le miracle qui à défaut d'une
telle aura la pression il donner
convient alors dit après 15 trous juste
pour par curiosité j'ai dit après 23h
lui donner
ça et bls droit qui monte en g3
fièrement on revient pas pu être fini
avec moi trop après le mot juste trois
ans rien ça rassure tout ça joue sajou
ou sajoo
j'envoie une pub
ça joue elle était important de salles à
celle là il change beaucoup de choses
hein ah bah on va être en vie et puis
bien comme il faut quoi bien bien comme
il faut quoi alors coin 3 - 3 je crois
que c'était fini honnêtement ça me
faisait très peur ouais ça va être tendu
c'était tendu
mathieu kim peek amiante est en train de
jouer elle a un truc au kazakhstan il a
gagné une belle partie le pari est gagné
travel meknès mcnabb verte à ses
premiers dans son tournoi régional et
les joints de chemises eau les arabes
qui ne l'a pas fait exprès de gagner
à ton avis qui lui a tout montré
je ne retiens rien bon alors plus simple
pour un prix car au cas où
bref maxime max maxime qui ajuste en
fait ouais c'est un peu éteint sur
quelques parties quoi passage à vide
mais bon à l'écart ou qui a fait un beau
match inquiets comme la force du caroux
sait quand même qu'il est très régulier
1 dans son match la veille la concept
mode diesel mais en fait tu es que
maxime une baisse de régime qui a fait
il a tout le temps jouer au même niveau
le niveau max de max et demain le niveau
maximum de max est supérieur à celui du
ko mais le truc c'est qui qu'a roues ou
le temps il est constant et du coude et
maxime baisse il le contre
à voir on va voir comment ça ça évolue
il reste il reste une heure de trois
plus un faudrait faut revenir un de
toute façon faut essayer faut essayer de
tourner à plus de 1 ça reste l'objectif
tout de même ouais déjà plus un stade
bien on va viser croit millions juste de
hockey non moi ce qui me fait peur c'est
avant la baisse de régime
c'est la baisse de régime qui m'a fait
peur après max il peut trouver le second
souffle un grand jeu des kakis qu'est ce
qui peut faire ça il faut du kaki way
pour s'alimenter quoi il ya que le kaki
qui peut s'armer du sucre à fond du coup
un nouveau sponsor comme juno là c'est
le sponsor à la finale wen jun ho il
faut quoi je sais pas ils sont 65 à
temps je vais regarder j'ai pas j'ai pas
eu le temps de regarder puis on m'a rien
écrit on m'a juste dit que c'était un
genou le sponsor mais on n'a pas dit ce
que c'était pour voir ce que c'est un
but le logo chemins se sont faits pour
être une sorte de l'aspirateur
non non c'est pas aspirateur je vais
dire ce que vous allez voir sur le site
et dites-nous 1
si les gens peuvent nous trouver ce que
c'est fait j'ai vu des tweets passé
puisque les mêmes même là en regardant
sur je n'arrive pas trop à comprendre
et on a regardé l'arrêt compris non plus
ouais mais je crois que pour elle c'est
qu'on a fait sauter leur site une
nouvelle fois comme avec alpha échec
parce que j'arrive à me connecter dessus
ouais ouais c'était terrible si on
réussit à aller dessus alesi mais je
crois malheureusement que leur site
marche plus trop de succès terrible
c'est une banque internet ils disent
mais a même fait un vrai progrès c'est
peut-être moins qui réussit pas à me
connecter dessus mais complexe j'ai vu
le logo en bas de l'écran
tiens c'est quoi ce truc base auncun
aurait d'après ce que c'est on fera ce
connecter sur leur site quoi c'est c'est
une autre question passionne journaux
que voilà fins et ils sont là quoi très
bien
c'est terrible c'est terrible pour un
genou enfin je vérifie juste que tout
marche bien partout bon jeu c'est oui ça
marche bien mais mais je préfère
vérifier tout de même
ouais ça fonctionne bien je regardais
combien il ya deux de gens qui supporter
voilà le carreau c'est terrible ce sont
nombreux chez les hétéros je sais pas
j'arrive pas à trouver mais oui
j'imagine c'est terrible dans les cas où
il est très concentré pas bouger de sa
chaise il est impressionnant il attend
peut-être pas bon signe pour lui une
soie qui dansent pas du tout il est
juste l'autre n'est très concentré
il est extrêmement focus where the most
powerful checking can't fight personnes
cash back to doc fifteen pearson sound
est positif mines et ben je sais pas
c'est le problème c'est que j'en sais
rien mon fab ont peu importe en fait
plaisir c'est dans la partie ils ont ils
ont gardé la fiche en se demandant si le
6 une finale d'un camurac arles scène
était et est inévitable quoi bah bah non
c'est terrible de demander ça quand même
mais c'est que quelle affiche le sort de
l'europe unie aujourd'hui
alors là je suis en train je suis allé
voir leur pub la même page de pub fin en
joon ho non par une jeune on a toujours
comme on dit oui dans un genre de truc
qui tournent ils ont gardé cette affiche
son double oublié d'enlever bas pas de
chance pas de chance oui il te repasse
les extraits des dernières finales
[Musique]
l'équipe yahoo qui dansaient l'année
dernière contre sow c'est terrible il
n'a fait le vin je ne sais pas j'aime
plutôt j'aime de moins en moins le
bullet en fait
[Musique]
ces bulles est à zéro on fait de la trop
vite joué des coups non en fait le truc
c'est quand tu aies joué en 3 + 0 même
les mecs super fort lennar audit ski ou
quoi en fait les parties elles sont
intéressantes
tu en ressors avec un truc
intellectuellement je n'ai pas assez
cool les bulles est en fait sur toiture
ressort juste quand des mecs qui
cliquaient plus vite que toi la souris
c'est pas une critique c'est tant mieux
pour eux et qui cuit fin ils
réfléchissent plus vite que toi et en
plus cycliques plus vite mais mais du
coup c'est un peu frustrant quand tu
perds parce que qu'est la partie
d'échecs est déjà pas intéressante et
même si tu réussis un peu faire le doute
aux échecs de toute façon même si tu
fais l'exploit d'être mieux de toute
façon ils cliquent plus vite que toi et
ils ont une meilleure connexion de ce
qu'ils sont aux états unis donc en fait
bon y les machines à café frigo die hard
way n'a max qui s'alimentent saison
mardi soit elle mène même si tu
réussissais avoir beaucoup de réussite
et que ton bullet se passe bien il
faudra encore que tu passes le truc
sourit donc c'est chiant est-ce
quelqu'un écran tactile soit plus de cas
la souris dont je pense pas un an sur le
don j'essaie souris ouais ouais
l'ajfer un sourire voilà des dieux avec
pourtant des autres l'assaut non je suis
assez lent par rapport à ces gars là je
suis très long ils sont vraiment très
rapide donc peut-être feinte ring souris
quoi bon il faudrait déplacer vite aller
d'un point a à un point b
un petit parcours sur l'écran et à
sauver tous à une énorme formation
training souris 1 par rapport à je suis
lent du coup c'est pas très amusant en
fait j'écoute pousser quoi soit devait
être face c'est le 19 et le 20 je sais
pas je viens de voir ça je te vient
aussi de faire moins d'événements fait
même pas au courant fin juin de voir ça
sur la pub quand j'ai vu leur pub
j'étais pas au courant mais probablement
encore non j'ai pas ils ont mis dix
mille dollars ou quoi j'ai l'impression
que c'est moins en moins gros que
l'année dernière où il ya deux ans j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas un très gros
de faim pas un très gros truc ça ah bon
truc mais déjà c'est sur deux jours avec
faste et sur cinq jours avec une phase
de qualification à une phase finale
c'est vraiment que sur deux jours j'ai
pas l'impression que ce soit énorme
et maxime on n'a pas parlé tu vois tu ce
truc là il m'aurait dit s'ils savaient
qu'ils le jeu quoi donc ça m'a l'air
d'être je pense à lui je sais pas ce que
ça va être mais ça a pas l'air d'être
soient pas les plus gros poissons
maintenant je pense pas qu'il voit sont
de taille normale bonne chance à être un
truc genre title tuesday avec une phase
finale un genre un gros qualificatif en
chais pas combien dont le premier jour
une phase finale le deuxième jeu n'a pas
l'air d'être un gros truc ça s'appelle
par world championship of bull est comme
ça lui était l'an dernier voire être un
truc beaucoup plus petits bourrelets
sert partie par partie et max qui
reprend sa ligne initiale pas de jets 6
mai ok bon échange un peu c'était une
semble acquis non mais c'est carrosse
qui a changé quatre ans une fusion qui
n'ont pas encore eu jusqu'à présent
et puis on verra ouais ils n'ont pas
encore eu celle là lors des quatre
heures puis on prend ou pas non il
temporise pour le moins avec dams et
cette esquive à rejouer les pleins et
que 5000 fâcheux 3 icheck il faut être
vite se met en place
tous ces deux bretons ne se remplacent
ceux des couples homos logique
maxime qui repart pas sur le 5 1 qui
j'avais pas trop réussi pour le moment
pas chacun soit en place avant qu'il ya
un clash au centre donc apprendre et
jouer au monde la tour est partie de la
colonnade pourquoi pas la logique je
sais s'il se défend b5 et peut-être cinq
maintenant ou occupant doit il menaça
cinq à six questions au fou peut-être
repartir vers 3 ou il échange de 5 mais
j'avais à 13.7 faire dame b cette
version est comme ça et garde la
protection du pion eux deux
donc fou des deux skis affaire d'âme
bessette c'est quand même vrai il met la
pression
ça recommence sur cinq il ya des fous
pour un f3 en plus c'est un bon pas
besoin il pourra peut-être aller
rechercher de la cola n'a vous détroit
où on est 6 e tr 7 e tour à 5 ou
provoque un truc là-bas alors caillage
ok il a déjà fait le coup tout à l'heure
ça te permet aux quais devenir berger 4
1 jour c'est pas dans les pionts est 4 h
5 pas plein de choses l'élan sur coup
des trois faisait d'eux sans raison et
on socialise à bassar vraiment rien
puisque maxime il a rien fait contre le
foot est roi quoi c'est pas il faut
enseignants du coup mon maximum et mieux
là c'est sûr que l'ouverture s'est bien
passé devant maxime eu trop de coups de
fouet de va et vient avec le vent allait
trop de coups bizarre f ou g 5 fu des
deux fous c'est un fou des 3c de détroit
ces deux ils envoient eux 5,66 aime
tellement la bonne pause pour max mais
bon ça retourne dans un truc un peu nous
déjà vu ou alors il est vraiment bien en
place il va tenter de cacher sa cavale
et qu'est ce qui va faire en rachète les
cinq de propager 5 je pense il fait ses
cadres pour le moment pour encaisser 5
et d 3 qui a déjà eu un peu un peu plus
tôt dans dans les partis qui aura lieu 4
friess prise dames c'est cet âge un son
qui car oui c'est bien mis à tourner sur
elle qu'elle est at il vraiment la
chance qu'un statut était pas le bon
coin
ouais je veux dire dans l'ue g5 je
comprend ici ils en achètent pour
stationner là bas elle aurait pu être en
d5 en fait tout le temps
on retrouvera un peu là il faut la tenir
neuf fois évident c'était arrive sur la
tête
il ya peut-être temps reprend dès qu'ils
franchissent non il n'y a pas de frein
f4 à la fin si tu prends tout jeter
oui pour le mans tu as raison même si
c'était peut-être pas si grave pour les
blancs mais ça ça a réouvert des
perspectives au noir voile alors hic
c'est qu'on prenne le temps de faire et
faire cavalier fuite qui a aidé cette
peut-être s'il a le temps j'ai 4 ans
appartient à l'attaqué fuite peut-être
pas facile bastien ça c'est un sas tient
à bastien sa vie un peu de partout ça
vient ça vient vers tours à 7,6 et 6,5
faut deux choses
le cavalier de devenir la rue 4 ou
allégées cinq partout mais qui voyait
finalement mieux placé maintenant qui
couvre les cases du fou le pion f4 sous
pression et le pur ou cinq qui va être
sous pression aussi allez allez allez
allez allez c'est à lille peut il peut
il peut revenir si le quart et les
bougies à cavaliers detroit
est ce qu'il est si mal tout rachat lice
prépare à rentrer colonna c'est très
logique pour attaquer le roi de maxime
pour conscription revenir en effet 6
avec le fouet me ranger 7 pour couvrir
la colonne h est en train de dîner puis
faut g7 on colmate pas mal ouais non là
on colmate d'agrafage et 5 kg
ouais mais ça passait de l'autre
inquiète pas ne t'inquiète pas ne
t'inquiète pas du tout la terre inquiète
alors qu'en réalité il ne faut pas
s'inquiéter cavaliers j'ai six fois ci
ça fou prend 1,5 fou prend pions pranger
5 et un petit carré détresse peut-être
qu'il va partir il ya du dam ces six
échecs dans la maxime y va ouais ça va
ça va il va faire le taf il va faire le
taf mon max où il ya aucun problème pour
les noirs le fou f4 et kata satanique
c'est un dame c6 intermédiaire vous
prendre deux points du champion pas mal
ces donations passé côté dames c'est cap
alors que se passe-t-il sur des deux il
veut simplement faire tourner un c'est
ça ouais et dams et 4 dames g6 d'un f4
tam h7 3f fuite tour f1 c'est ça le
prend là et si on prenait 2 ouais
c'était sûrement ça l'a libéré prisé des
deux alors ici tu aurais fuite mais
c'est logique
alors est-ce qui menacent quelque chose
[Musique]
bref ça c'est ok je pensais que j'avais
peur de damas huit dans ma vie de cette
fois fuite juste donc il vient la fff 8
prises des trois fous c'est simple aïe
non ya pas trop grave car apprend encore
9,3 bref c'est peut-être ça qui l'a
ratée ya pas tourcoing f4 marlou dead
ouais enfin le piège d'hikaru bon c'est
pas grave je peux craquer comme encore
l'autre pour tuer en émoi mais bon qui
est surtout la paire avec les noirs
sanaa mais bon ok je dois les plus
charmants s'il revient c'est terrible
allez faut tenir
ouais ouais mais hockey est roi c'est
beau passer si c'est long il va encore
tout ça les tours et du conseil l'un à
temps à temps pourquoi nul 3 échecs
enfin le cynisme
malheureusement mais bon on espère et on
espère et hikaru qui va jouer là le
temps peut-être
ouais c'est sûr alors il propose nul il
ne fait pas en finale ou encore pas
encore ma contre eux soit ils avaient
commencé tôt un affaires qui n'auraient
pas de cette variante monclar longtemps
il a raison mais la maxime il va voir il
va il a parlé au coach d'abord d'alpha
wen mais il a parlé au coach et ça va
faire très très mal à icare ou le cahier
va parler à les cavaliers à 5 à
peut-être fait le fou quillan g5 quand
même pour provoquer
6 le carnet qui part et maxime qui boit
un peu d'eau après avoir sorti le coût
du carnet etienne nous dire et qui
connaît pas placer sur jamais vu
l'espagnol connaît pas ne sais pas quoi
connais pas et tiennent donc à faire
quoi faire car il y eu quatre pour
essayer de viser peut-être cette case
cette case of six mois ou deux mais
d'abord je sais pas pourquoi pas qu'ils
envoient le cavalier pour du cavalier f6
échec peut-être du fou g5
j'aime bien non c'est pas mal pas mal
c'était de position
les cinq kayakistes qui va partir ou
cavaliers fils direct elle est sympa
cette position à jouer allez max avait
laissé six trous g5 intermedia affluer 5
kg dames prendre le guen pion à laurent
software 4 ha soit les carrés vip 6 puis
la finition ouais ouais c'était un peu
beaucoup de ram et l'autre camp ces
quatre donc ben ok oui il veut faire et
qu'ils essaient 5 d'autres un mot un
truc ou crise prises sous g5 et quelque
chose à mes à ça en fait en l'air tout
bêtement prise frisa me prends à 5
hockey demeure damiens très bien joué et
survient vallier c4 il va sûrement lui
planter un cavalier c'est simcoe et a eu
six ou quelque chose comme ça cavalier
de des cuatro attendais pas car il est
prêt et d'emprunt à 5 ha non il ya fou
prend 1,4 non mais attends ça peut
marcher ça c'est pas possible
tipi qui auront des cavaliers pros en
full 3d prend b2 attend cavaliers prend
dame prend damas 5-fu prend tour d un
homme soit 4,4 ça tellement la tête d'un
truc qui fonctionne pas un an pour eau
pure peut-être prendre kayentis aussi
n'avons en réseau le père de soutien
alors je mets un coup d'arrêt disent pas
possible que ça tienne ça si ça marche
et laurent foostie conseils trucs pareil
si vite
mais comment tu vois ça
impressionnant ondimba alors dit on dit
que c'était le seul coup d'après lors
des cas et des quatre mais comment tu
trouve en fait fort ça a tellement ça
tellement la tête du truc qui marche
jamais non bach que des cci qui est donc
ce qui m'impressionne c'est toujours
qu'ils prennent édition si vite je puis
finir par le trouver pourquoi pas mais
c'est dire ça s'est trouvé en 3 secondes
non mais trouver ça en partie longue ou
quoi oui même en semi rapide peut-être
mais en blitz rebond d'autres options ce
qui est connu juste pour une raison x ou
y qui connaissait la position est simple
si possible tout le monde ça bon du coup
en un tournemain toujours été incroyable
ce qu'il a trouvé
j'arrive pas à croire que tu puisse
trouver ça aussi vite si tu l'a jamais
vu ça me paraît tellement fort tellement
bien joué il est vraiment impressionnant
et piarroux a mêlé fort hills est pas
pour rien qu'il est numéro un mondial en
blitz un niveau je pense quand même pour
le fait qu'ils connaissent et fab le
thème technique ok mais attend à ses
compétences à son profit pour 7 ou fade
ouais voilà d'autres fronts c'est un peu
la mère de dames au 6 juin ça peut être
suffisant parce que je n'ai chaque fois
même si c'est un échec c'est tout mais
là hikaru cette partie là il est juste
incroyable non on se re aussi de trouver
une vente qui est chiante formation ça
ils prenaient l'autre partout la
berlinoise avec ça on n'a même pas vu
l'ombre d'un avantage en trois parties
je vais bien impression de base d'antrim
mais en fait il a vu se presser 5 bien
comme il fallait il n'a trouvé sa
ressource machin n'est pas finie elle
est pas fini encore femmes puisqu'il
encore encore encore un truc de marloux
vrai bien joué et bien joué car on a
franchement rien à dire mais ok il va
quand même la perdre c'est ça qui est
dommage
je n'ai pas suffisant dames 5 sada 25
retour au caire au moins j'ai mis 9 nuls
pas mieux est-ce qu'on peut aller
prendre au théâtre au passage non c'est
non c'est bien eu tort de passer là mais
c'est un passage difficile et boissons
et s'accroche mais un peu comme hier
face à face à manu j'ai eu un passage
difficile il s'accroche c'est maintenant
qu'il faut qu'il faut y aller a laissé
bien il faut qu'il retrouve du vivant
avec les noirs il a été bien dans la
première partie de match en fait ils
commencent à se faire prendre dans
toutes les positions et maxime c'est
l'impression que ça me donne fab
ça c'est très bien avec les blancs avec
les noirs là après partie 3-4-5 même
même 1 2 3 4 5 6 la nasa 7 qui était pas
beau défi et il se refait planté en
tactique mais là ça il se fait planter
des trucs
j'étais pas très rigolo qu'est ce que ce
que c'est grave ça la regarde pas que
c'est fini on fait ça il faut qu'on
accepte un match 5 oui bah je devrais
jouer je viens qu'est-ce qu'il attend ça
allait tellement vite il apprit à 5.5
pris aux 5,5 tout tempo moitié
7 c'est juste qu'il me faisait perdre ce
qui me faisait peur en fait max d'âge
c'est ce qui est cette soirée et tué 36
matchs et bonbons dommage ça craque la
ccc physique un fab
bon ben je sais pas quoi dire quoi faire
ben fait tellement mal pas comme ça
zinedine
alors on a pris un coup derrière la tête
fab ouais ouais bon ok on va
non mais c'est dur c'est un homme en dur
c'est pas toi en un peu comme si on fait
l'élastique en vélo si jamais très bon
faudrait classique s'arrête pas qu'on
revient dans le groupe qui est une
longue descente un peu tranquille c'est
vrai mais après quand même c'est que
quand ça remonte si je suis à 80
kilomètres de descente à très très long
quoi après juste une petite montée de
500 mètres pour le final voilà justement
j'ai passé existe ce genre de profil
d'étape avec des descentes de 80 km tu
te retrouves à 5000 mètres sous la mer
tu fini l'étape avec le tube à afat été
mal quoi à ce poste c'est peut-être même
pire chimie en scaphandre quoi on a déjà
vu ce plan tout à l'heure ouais c'est
pas mal fou prend 1 h 6 dames prince six
cavaliers ces deux questions kg saint
calais il revoit des trucs maxime
il faut il faut il faut il faut soutenir
maxime faut soutenir notre champion il
va prendre g7 et reprendre ces deux
évidemment il voulait pas prendre la
qualité dans tous les cas c'était trop
dangereux avec les français et qui a
aidé de caisse et quatre non ouais ça
c'est bien ton art 10 h 80 voilà il est
plutôt bien plus tôt même très bien à 4
s et bien joué ici venu à sin qu elle
parle elle aussi tout tout contre eux ça
casse b5 pas toujours pas de tirer dans
cette case
personne ici tout va à 20 ne pas quitter
après vent de ce cahier des quatre
mètres un pion à la place il a lancé
c'est ce qu'il est en train de réaliser
ou bien ils tours troyes et tours à 20
c'était quoi c'est simple en fait tu as
besoin de calculer tu es bien combien
sans effort après il y aura un moment
pourra calculer en fait pour 7 bis mais
passée la skycar hausse est de
construire comme défense il va pas nous
laisser gagner sans effort et c'est pour
ça que c'est aussi dommage la partie
précédente c'est pas vraiment le fait
d'avoir perdu puisque ça en perdre on en
perdra encore mais c'est le fait de lui
avoir donné une partie sans effort ou si
on fait pas cavalier prend et cavaliers
b 2-2
il est seul à eghezée 6,5 ouais il y en
a deux qui ont été perdus en cadeaux
entre guillemets c'est deux points de
vente
ouais nettoie et fin bon
très bien bon enfin peut calculer mais
ça c'est bien mais c'est un bon sens
avait il fait tous les coups normaux
sans calculer c'est bon c'est fait du
bien de voir un peu jouer des coups
comme ça mais elle joue un coup bouger
une pièce ça et vite et bien besoin de
souffler mais j'ai 4 g 20 le 2 mai il a
bien joué et laïque armand en défense un
parcours maxima est ce mieux il n'a pas
à son avantage s'est pas évaporé mais
c'est très mieux mais à maurice avoir
calculé pour gagner va perdre tout seul
alors que dans les positions comme ça
contre beaucoup de beaucoup de joueurs
tu gagnes sans jouer un tour à tour h4
ah non il défend comme ça et sur carey
lady silva f 4 mai sur quatre tableaux
quatre fois il attendait que ça à temps
mais maxi maxi y en a placé une conne
j'ai passé à gagner pas la fin et
quincaillerie prend huit dames g7 maths
mais bon j'ai pas eu le temps de
calculer c'est quand même plus d'autres
cold asphalt avec des zooms d'amour il
ya quand même la force a calculé une
petite phase où on peut se sont
embrouillées je crois que ça va aller là
maintenant aller hyper importante elle
est vraiment hyper importante celle là
bas ce truc ce giro qu'il nous faut
c'est dame prend ya le floch et donc on
attaque des six et ça c'est bien ça va
gagner psion mais j'en vois la perruque
peru peru pour la fin du match j'en peux
plus je suis en sueur mais dans l'autre
sens ce sens qu'elles sont non mais
attends je vais enfin en fait j'avais le
mauvais retours écran allumé du coup
j'avais un retour écran terrible qu'avec
un avec avec des décalages
j'ai envoyé la perruque mai
pas fini la partie je pensais que ça se
finirait pendant je mettrai la période
qui est finalement s'agit pas bon ok
mais ouais je tombe bien c'est quand
même un bon piont de plus le roi adverse
est dans les cordes tour si ce qui peut
passer
il nous fait c'est cathy temps de son
contre je tombais passé mais bientôt
réussissent à l'art de faire mal je vois
pas où est le problème
je sens que ça gagne direct en fait
c'est simple je sais pas moi je la même
si ce dernier 6,8 ça m'agace car ils
abandonnent aller ok allez qu'un point
avec un auteur
non plutôt aller aller faut y aller faut
le terminer
fab il faut revenir là faut égaliser il
reste combien de temps on sera plus un
il reste 37 minutes 37 il reste quand
même assez de temps allez faut arrêter
faut arrêter les cadeaux la fin surtout
miles et quand vous propose 5,7 enfin
pas trop tôt on va le prendre plus tard
mr comestibles non noël c'est danser
dans douze jours encore fab
il faut il faut il faut terminer le
terminer le boulot on pensera aux
cadeaux plus tard donc saraka la bourse
a l'impression que depuis un moment une
façon qualif 1 kg 3 ces 2 h 3 entre les
couples on les connaît ça changeait tout
à l'heure donc il avait fait ça comment
c'était dams et 7 5 pions prend pions
prend kyi et dé 5,4 a lieu quatre les
prend 1,5
ça avait perdu comme ça quand il est
fier
pourquoi il a fait ça tempo d'air un
petit coup d'impulsivité s'est passé
quelque chose comme pas ce que c'est
ok mais c'est une potion gaulle devant
normal enfin on l'a déjà vu plein de
fois et blanc on veut le faire leur
machin les droits et maxdb bien avec des
5 c 4 ça on a déjà dit et on va voir
mais lalalalala ses chances assez
équilibré comme position ouais c'est
complètement équilibré montfa ben vous
voyez du pcot a trop on s'en prend aux
pions c3 cette fois avec paella
passereaux il a une bonne position là
ils attaquent en premier un fab
après bon il va sacrer les droits on a
le roi en jeu par rapport à ceux des
pions mais ouais mais il sort il semble
quand même être un peu en avance allez
l'égalisation était au bout de cette
partie fab aller à laisser ça là il pas
une autre
allez peut-être faut faire gaffe c'est
celle là et les autres
ouais et les autres exactement je viens
est ce qu'on peut faire un genre de tour
un fou prend f3 cavaliers detroit tu
vois et d'enchaîner les coups de butoir
est parti de l'autre côté pour la
colonne c'est pas mal il vise la case d3
pour son cavalier c'est bien joué
beaucoup il ya toujours de la ccit si
par exemple 8,6 et la grande diagonale
et c'est donc coutume a pas l'air mal du
tout que les fuites qui tient la maison
là bas donc même lesquels 5% n'a pas
peur et je ne sais pas comment il veut
nous attaquer côté blanc on verra ce qui
va faire quelque chose un truc c'est
quand tu fais h cinq cavaliers detroit
ça te permet de fermer la diagonale du
fou dont qui manque une pièce en attaque
maintenant côté côtes américains un pion
prend des trois qui peut arriver à une
petite dame qui vit en b 6 pouces et 5
mois est là il est il est mieux il est
mieux max a poussé sa moyenne m dames
j'ai cinq premières 3 où il n'ya pas
d'un point y avait des deux ça c'est
bien il est pas loin d'hama yacoub et
katia daria dame ces deux thèmes qui
donne envie oui mais c'est de fouler
cassette deux coussins pas
tu prépares aussi poussé 5 peut-être
dans l'enchaîner les dames c'est de il
veut quoi il veut il veut d'amd de
hockey oui mais bon
non juste fan je veux dire comment
comment on finit en fait faut le
terminer la course et s'est pas terminée
mais il ya eu 6 carats lien qui va
pouvoir rejaillir 17,5
ouais et sinon rebond bien versé 5 b3 ou
je ne sais pas par là bas donc là et ça
c'est très cool complexe dam des deux
semble le seul coup non parce que des 2
c for food et 2 il ya dame prend b2 de
toute façon déjà au caire soit dame b3
pour se garder des fous b4 damas quatre
combats dams et j'adore j'adore ce coup
puisque tu es qualifié 5 qui avait trois
en fait c'est ta pièce qui joue le moins
et en deux coups tu la ramènes a laissé
l'égalisation là à laymont fab on
revient quand la perruque sorti au bon
moment les gens et il va nous falloir
beaucoup de marloux ainsi gagné cette
partie je pense qu'il va faire envoyer
un mur de marloux important le mur de
marloux et qui va partir en c5 j'imagine
ouais c'est fait et ça et qui masque et
b3 maintenant qui va venir en plus tapé
la casse c'est en cas d' échanges
préparer du tour d un
c'est en train d' extrêmement bien se
passer pour le joueur français
c'est parfait le cavalier b3 et le fou
c5 et le d2 j'ai l'impression que c'est
fini maxime qui va qui va la chercher
celle là tu vas prendre ta vie de trois
nouveaux ça peut aller bien loin
juste pour ses 8 j'ai fixée ne bouge
plus il bouge plus du tout il fait d'un
f4 il tant ils tentent souvent plus les
changes les chances pratique mais je
crois que ce qui se passe sur des deux
de voir un tour d2 à la fin un truc
comme ça faut grands qui les prend trop
de ballons peu comme en a on peut pas
commencer par couper on peut commencer
par fous ces cinq par contre
ouais autour des 4 h par des coups juste
un coup comme ça on est fous j'ai cinq
ans et empêcherait mais bon attention à
karaj que trois autres sont autre idée
de marloux amical trônera et des deux
qui a essayé deux pions prend il défend
la photo pas du couple est fou c'est 5
quand même tour des quatre c'était
réussi le pensions mais attendez cap et
h 6 arrêts du coup il lui prend la case
de 3 pour le cavalier très fin et foulée
4 et très bien que c'est l'égalisation
allez on revient
3121 pour maxime égalise
c'est super qu'il existe comme ça on
était quand même au fond du trou ya pas
longtemps on était on était mal après le
drame prend 1,5 et maxime qui va le
chercher il nous faut beaucoup de marc
lula dans le chat je pense du marlou et
du lait de la fusée marleau fusée je
pense marlou fusée à les gens mais un
petit peu ce qu'on vaut quoi ouais je
sais pas je sais pas je sais pas si j'ai
sous la main mais oui il faut il me faut
un marlou et je mets juste un mario une
fusée de fusées trois fusées jeu mais
quand même un peu plus de fusées et je
les entoure de marloux et djédjé ils
s'ordonneront assez l'italienne qui est
parti en attendant ouais c'est la notion
d'auteur plus ou moins on a déjà eu
l'avantagé on a eu davantage la trois et
demi deux ennemis dans ce match et il
reste à dire est qu il reste une demi
heure de 3 + 1 à les femmes on est
encore l'objectif plus de la qui est
faisable
oui il peut enchaîner mac ça oui c'est
cette fameuse position elle femme au zoo
qu'ils avaient déjà eu dans le skimming
open qu'il en dise et quoi qu'ils
connaissaient pas non à la d2 ou d3 qui
a laissé six web qui connait paraît d'un
meutre non en fait on avait préparé
c'était prépare pendant le truc en fait
pendant les commentaires on a on a
préparé pendant les commentaires il bat
qui disait toujours mieux pour les
blancs salle qui a aidé 4 domine le fou
on y avait eu exactement cette position
je suis quasiment sûr voire même
carrément sa position donc bonne
nouvelle de retomber là-dedans si blake
qui est en fait ce qu il expliqué c'est
qu'avec les noirs tu as une faute de
de perdre en fait de perdre j'aimerais
pas voir la notation le problème c'est
hyper dur vous est très fort très fort
précis il connaît il analysé pas dire
que je pense était lâché là dedans par
toi même c'est très dur mais je
comprends et décale j'adore le foot et 7
j'adore mois l'option des cinq isolé f4
f5 qui peut partir il ya beaucoup
d'atouts dans la position problème c'est
qu'il faut faire marcher un truc et sada
manger si c'est pas mal qui les
travaille avec le fou j'ai 17 pour
attaquer chez quatre niveaux faire des
contrôles sur le roy keane en train de
nous faire un peu alors d'un côté il
fait du contre jeu mais d'un autre côté
il se compromet un peu son roi aussi à
voir mais même les finales en fait
cavalier contre fous sont sympas ben
écoute
allez il faut il faut il faut il faut
faire le taf il faut terminer le travail
côté côté max et reprendre enfin
l'avantagé dans ce match aller d'un rêve
de ses biens il blindes dublin ii le roi
il s'en prend un peu à la tour
il prépare un peu f4 f5 elle est bien
placée cette dame qui a aidé quatre qui
bloque la casse ces deux donc les noirs
peuvent jamais rentré il veut s'il veut
se procurer la can
une case in yvelinois mais peut-être des
tourbes et un comme ça pourquoi du joug
à quoi sert takase battre il va prendre
en b cette voie là des soldats tombés
trois du coup je pense alors à près des
quais en v5 à regarder mais je pense pas
qu'on a envie de le prendre celui-là ça
donnerait la casse ces deux c'est pas
intéressant
harakat si on prend un tour d'essai le
juge bien bien bien je les connais bien
jouer voilà maxime saillie à repasser
il a passé les tests supersonique
d'équipier ouais alors à temps et encore
pour ses sets mais peut-être qu'en fait
il est très content que il ya une
tournoi cette colonne 77,5 balader et
peux tu peux peut-être plus de trucs
dont cavalli peut se balader aussi son
défendre ses deux sets
cette soulage aussi vanasse et hormis
les quatre contre attaque
je suis pas sûr que ce soit suffisant je
suis pas sûr que ce soit suffisant
fab bon temps d'un et après ça la
question
tour d un bref deux réussissent aussi
c'est quand même est très compliqué mais
les jolies intéressant je sais pas ce
que ça va donner mais oui du coup puis
on prend cavaliers prend il va faire fou
prend pour prendre tour est fait pour ça
bref 2 et pour ces deux peut-être juste
nul ouais tu peux revenir en lin est ce
que ce roi noir je dois pas si faible en
battant la voir ouais nan c'est nul
bon ok je ne sais pas c'est grave parce
que j'entends lotis de la joue pour
gagner six avions plus avancée mais bon
ça va être nul même hormis l'assomption
des bien sûr mais le roi comme je vois
mal échappé à tous les pères faute et
compagnie voilà oui mais déjà il faut en
fait c'est à nous de faire attention ici
parce que nous par contre on est encore
dans le car ici ça échange les dames 1
oui c'est important portant l'important
exactement sur le carré parce que mapaq
le pion puisqu il ya tout cela des dons
il peut pas nous faire enfin si nous
propose un échange des dames on peut
l'accepter donc dames 5 joué y menacent
de prendre et sur des trois dames 4 un
échec qui ronge d'options oui on mange
le bifff que ça c'est cool d'aveux 3 on
peut prendre juste échangé à damas trois
d'échangés rage est un roi roi match à
étudier une option donc il ya rien voilà
donc là c'est le drame des deux le
codeur cela se rendre à damas c'est
juste perpète n'ont peut-être trois g3
wave c'est pas son recul sur neuf ne la
met pas fin les deux voleurs très bien
tam g6 il va faire froid f2 12 je pense
écoute ça se trouve on joue pour le guen
aurait enfin non je dis pas non mais
mieux la stratégie de cet ouvrage et 3
es tu peux rien faire ok c'est bien
c'est pas n'y pas de souci il reste
combien de temps peut-on tirer de d'y
retourner dans cette danse
ouais bah c'est sûr je pense qu'il peut
y retourner il va finir par en gagner
une mère avec le noir est ce que nos
problèmes sont réglés
que je me pose pas dans la partie
précédente ils ont été réglés oui mais
j'ai en fait on était tellement mal
souvent que ça va continuer à faire peur
quoi qu'il en soit c'est là même où il
ya une différence
j'ai dit aux 4es machin non non non le
foot ensuite à huy avait poussé deux
avants intermédiaire et dans ce n'est
pas tout à fait la même ouais ils vont
peut-être pierre vincent c'est dur je
veux dire qu'il prend en prend un écart
ou qui il a retourné une faute car
pinson ouais mais bon enfin si tu
comptes avec les blancs finalement
envoyé lu du bien et du moins bien c'est
vrai non mais c'est plutôt pas mal pour
lui son choix comme jeu des parties
intéressantes avec les blancs sans y
être mais sa 38e dit que c'était lui
fois quoi qu'il joue ce à quoi on n'a
pas tout à fait il a tout renvoyé notre
âme et la tour en 1 8 d'habitude cette
date une amélioration ce rayon des 8èmes
38 bon allez et sur la sphère du p5
probablement téléfoot ou b 5 points des
deux coups sûrs - le prochain à moins
que les prendre cinq nouveaux comptes
c40 ksar perdent immédiatement fin aux
lacunes dans son jeu en vue de sa vie
c'est moins rapide tour a sûrement avec
gérard exceptionnel quand l'afrique
repères et tout de suite tg5 encore est
bon alors il coûte cher tombe dans ce
truc c'est comme au début du match bâtir
une structure sauf que cette fois on n'a
pas donné la teneur de fou donc tu assez
confiant dans l affaire attention pour
les hommes mais la dame parte
oui je sais on met en évidence et 7,5 je
voulais y menacé vraiment ce des deux
coups cemac cela se replaçant ces
scissions ouais non mais il est mieux je
conseille de potes qui coachent année va
changer ça qu'on se faire deux parties
de suite où elle plus rien ouais c'est
pas qu'il a plus rien mais c'est qu'il a
vraiment rien élu roi et dont j'ai faim
avant il a eu là il a eu des paires de
fou il a eu des trucs mélasse et ses
îles et de nouveaux pas très bien le
cavalier qui repart angers ici ce qui va
viser f4 qui va jouer avec le full a ses
avantages maximin oui et c'est plutôt
lui qui contrôle les colonnes d donc
après je suis en sait pas assez mais bon
il va presser est-ce que tu mets ton car
ayant un f4 quand même c'est bien ce
temps fort la whey non mais ya juste eu
c'était c'était un passage à vide de
maxime en fait ce qu'on ait enfin le
niveau général de maxime est meilleur
mais mes hikaru le niveau moyen est ça
ça va être niveau niveau sprint contre
niveaux de fond quoi savoir lequel est
ce que maxime va réussir à garder son
niveau de jeu élevé assez longtemps faty
car oui la sortie sur les seize ont eu
plusieurs grosses parties mais on a
sorti une très très grosse c'est celle
où il a joué le quartier des 4 tempo là
après c'était peut-être n'était pas il
m'a fait quelques universel là c'était
vraiment la partie où il a tout dépend
de la dose de carburant dans la fusée
ouais
carburant kaki 1 du kaki qui a été vite
dans la fusée a c'est pas mal parce que
si fort ses katas qui peut prendre faire
à 5 et fixe des trucs là mais oui mais
oui valeur des 4 et le h5 de toute façon
existe voilà il est bien bel et bien là
il est bien et allez ça serait tellement
beau prendre l'aventage je garde c'est
un petit coup de détresse - 2 conçu et
géré la dernière partie du 5% mais tu tu
remarques que sa tournée après la grosse
punchline que j'ai lâché quand même sur
les candidats ouais je pense être
punchline a fait tellement de bien à
tout le monde
face à change rien pour le match 1 mais
nous elle nous a fait tellement de bien
passer le courant du bac c'est pas tout
cas la punchline était lâché bon alors
c'est petit à 5
je pense qu'il va willis le fait un
temps qui peut le garder un ton qui peut
ne pas perdre de temps pour le jouer il
le fait par m et du basset loti le faire
mais bon maintenant il en compte plus
quand même ça dure au maximum d'actions
ça me fait plaisir on va se fait plaisir
et je te confirme que nous d'oublier
tour j'imagine alors attends l'otiv
koala dans les fers pour au 5 août ces
attentats envie de t'en veux toujours de
regarder qui a eu 2 qui est venu voir
les matchs henry s'il a raté qui marche
mais bon restons juste et si je vous
disais est ce qu'on fait passer mon tour
des huit ans que ces tours 5e bombe
entre bravo étape cavalli pas nantes a
pas mais franchement et cavaliers fils
manqué f5 fera pailladins brandam mais
bon on te ra du dame b 4 mai prochain
il voulait éteindre ce sont des gauchers
c'est parce qu'il est sur tours 5
mais il va il va s'en faire coller
planté à la temps qu'elle prend b3
maintenant marbre l'imprenable tour
prend d un héros black ça donne et car
il y prend un homme ça marche
ouais trajet bien calculé je suis
content and on attend attend d'un
premier quatre tours d un tour eu un
badaud points 1-1 pour prendre un fort
surprend ouais ouais ouais ça doit
marcher ça va marcher
bref à ben ali l'a fait comme ça ah oui
menace la dame est encore plus simple et
tourcoing d1 et cavaliers sait ce qu'est
ce que aïcha et ses deux ça gagne pas
non qu'ils essaient de yahvé tour il y
avait tout retour j'ai un an il a été ma
route et alors qu'il ya trois ans son
fils a fait rien c'est pas facile
[Musique]
cette chance quoi les chiens il a eu
dans cette vie ce chat nakamura est une
réussite de ouf quand même d'avoir sa
patte était passée on va la perdre ce
caillou 7 sur le tient en fait une sorte
de forteresse
on va voir non mais genre il avait rien
calculé d'avancé en fait je sais en fait
ils tombent dessus il a ce truc
miraculeux et mais du coup ça va parfois
c'est l'horreur tu peux checker c'était
mieux ton truc où tourne trop tard je
veux checker reste yeux parker et
s'avère bien peu tchèque ce tube en deux
secondes
basée là-dessus aime bien prendre b4
tour francs d un américain de 61 tours
prend d un tour heureux et dames un
pardon dans ce sens soit très bon dans
les faits c'est bon mais ouais enfin ça
c'est nous qui nous en sortons bien si
on s'en sort oui ok le truc était
tellement tentant mais marché pas à quoi
je crois et de stickers dans quel monde
ça marche son truc comment ça a fait
pour fonctionner ce truc là
pourquoi
alors c'est pas possible on en veut
tellement daigle a bon allez via qu'un
point d'écart maxime il vaut mieux quand
même il joue mieux il est plus fort quoi
c'est relou c'est relou n'a autant les
les matchs précédents contre hikaru il
avait vraiment été dominés autant ce
soir je trouve qu'il est plus fort je le
trouve au dessus je le trouve au dessus
et là il ya encore une bonne position
l'intrus qui est parti c'est terrible
non mais bon ça va ça va tourner dans le
match avec des noirs quand même je pense
qu'il a solutionné le problème du tout
ces quatre mais peut-être un poil
montréal une comme moi vous demander
d'autres utiles damas 3 peut-être pour
allait raser le pion ok c'est qui c'est
quoi pour ces 1
on est juste qu'il est sain qui est bien
passé qu'est donc il s'en prend à lui je
vais peut-être qui sait tout mais bon on
n'y aura que les g5 et ce 7 mai et 5
pour la route si ça va mal aller on est
de nouveau bien on s'est fait voler dans
la dernière crème c'est arrivé tellement
bien défendu hikaru et la réussite un
petit peu mais mais mérité cette dame
ces deux pour tous et à dammaj 400 pas
réussi
il a plutôt une leçon pas mal un
problème c'est que rien renfe avec alors
c'est relativement solide aussi il est
solide et solide tour est un atout qui
va s'échanger il reste combien de temps
treize minutes soyons rêver d'un plus de
on va essayer d'aider à une égalité à
égaliser c'est faisable c'est qu 1 point
ouais que serait plus sain qu'il serait
vraiment bien plus simple serait très
bien vrai allez le cavalier 3 il
menacera cas relief 5 au passage bon
déjà il faut dire si mal aux pieds des
buts on peut s'expliquer on est pour bat
bullet et j'avais obligé de perdre c'est
mais bon il car où il est quand même oui
c'est son truc c'est son royaume
on vient f4 et non n'est pas mieux c'est
quoi 5 +13 puisse influencer les
cadences de jeu le premier chiffre 5 3 1
ce temps en minutes au départ et puis ça
c'est à dire chaque coup qui jouèrent
gagner une seconde au creux ce qui n'est
pas grand chose mais qui peut éviter de
perdre autant à la fin est plus mieux il
se fait visser
la perdre pour autant si on fait nuance
est nul c'est comme ça moi l'est pas
moins bien c'est un bon port tout un peu
moins bien joué dame f5 sur d'impromptus
on prend il va ramener le carillon en
effet il a le droit de tourner plus vite
il a deux trois petits trucs à faire
valoir comme un canard mais bon notre
côté tant qu'à et dames sur l'échiquier
sonrhaï plus faible de tête juste à 9,3
ou ailleurs ces deux québécoises peuvent
aussi blesser 7 sur échec donc pas donc
tous qui trop de choses dont cinq qui
tourne en rond peu d'hommes de main à a3
et sécurisé ou si c'est sûr d'un prince
et 7h 4 c'est bien joué chez fx il
empêche les 6 5 mais c'est pas clair
quand on est comme ça du bouquet bis
tisci et ses 4 sera toujours des trucs
dans les finales aussi mais ce que tu as
à me les ges que cette finale est si
mauvaise mais alors à qui arrive vite en
f4 c'est ça le problème
la dame sait pas ce qu'il veut faire bam
adam 8 ya dameuse 5 à celle à vue hinse
tentation est clair bon mais bon c'est
pas si ce qu'est le danger c'est que
laurent blanc peut sembler mal mais d'un
autre côté c'est bien plus de l'avion
devant donc tu vas devoir tu vas pouvoir
contrer normalement même ses limites je
serais parti voilà huit pouces et 8 à
huit ça donne peut-être plus de coeur
étaient privés c'est un pion hockey à
wimbledon dont il s'est retiré d'un café
leffe un roi ici kadrige étroits
d'amitié il empêche d'aller fin aussi
ouah ouah c'est compliqué le milieu
d'hommes il veut tout en fait il veut
qui épate des cinq pattes damas à lui
atteint 9,5 aussi possible il veut
qu'elle ait faim et vous tous les
cookies et des deux savants 2005 roger
kay les deux ça fait peur quand même
idem des cinq dames des 4es
[Musique]
ok elle est de toute façon c'était
sûrement le seul coup puisqu'elle
cavaler afin qu'ils traînaient m'adapte
emploi défendu quelle est la fourchette
demeurant cavaliers et cahiers faim
d'amour qu'il valait surtout d'alger 3
mg de magna c'était jour 12 à la menace
en fait avec courage mais davin c'était
un geste est l'idée première c'est de
nouveau difficile c'est incroyable quoi
puisque dès qu'on ait une dynamique
ouais mais ouais mais pas de réussite en
la partie d'avant et celle là du coup
c'est dur c'est dur moralement et car on
joue bien ici la série il a très bien
joué avec les marins bon finalement
nulle
après cette cession ça va je prends il
reste deux parties les carreaux qui
réalise un qui rallie qui réalise un
beau matin quand même il est bon bon
j'aime bien plus ambitieux une sorte
d'estrade heineken qui globalement dans
les ouvertures avec les noirs il a quand
même ça y est bien sorti 1 bizarrement
ça avec les blancs qui n'a pas obtenu
autant qu'ils pourraient entre
guillemets on a l'impression mais bon il
est chanson de jessy ch'ti quand il a
laissé bien pour son style il trouve du
jeu tout voilà il a réussi a failli là
il a réussi à prévoir un plan b si la
berlinoise se passait mal et son plan b
la tenue on l'aurait fait on lui aurait
fait sauter le pub le plan b c'était moi
de penser
ouais je pense pas non à un moment assez
bien ouais dont il entraînait une
vilaine évoque non non j'ai montré hier
contre yves l équipe de france on est
ensemble
[Musique]
le pam attribuer le rôle d'entraîneur ce
serait malhonnête c'est baky depuis
longtemps ce nom sont sont seulement
dans ace qui constituent les cavaliers à
quatre intermédiaires mais non ça marche
c'est parfois j'ai l'impression que de
nouveaux noms péremption mon père b4
ouais c'est bizarre qu'on ait besoin
fatigue il avec son caddie de 4 nous a
mis un peu dans le dur s'est passé
tellement anodin c'est une vertu il a
été il a été très très bon a ni carreaux
et car oui c'est un rat un des rares
joueurs qui a un qui travaille avec un
mec qui est pas super fort
little john sait plus comment il
s'appelle qui est de 1100 d'actualité ou
je sais pas mais ouais ou peut-être
c'est juste pour une compagne les
tournois puis qu'il s'en fiche je sais
pas trop ce qui donne donc boulot pascal
un problème devant un mec de ce nouveau
enfin il peut te faire trouvera un ordi
c'est pas le problème mais pour vous
prendre toutes les finesses et qu'est ce
qui est jouable en partie humainement on
pas une machine c'est une chose ouais
ouais je mets mes pour ça que j'ai c'est
un des rares joueurs qui travaillent
avec un avec un amateur entre guillemets
[Musique]
mais ça lui réussit pas mal
non mais il a fait ça comme ça ils sont
fichus personne parce que tu as sur les
joues plus en partie longue
[Musique]
enfin quoique il est à ce prix il est
quand même bien préparé pour ces trucs
sur internet
ça m'est à son châssis a tellement fait
de boulot dans sa vie que ça ne sera pas
comme ça mais c'est vrai aussi mais tout
va
or jouer l'espagnol justice en partie
longue travail se faire exploser oui et
dans la berlinois je pense que contre un
mec comme maxime il enfin en partie
longue qui souffrirait vraiment mais
pour le blitz et les rapides ça suffit
il est bon mais la position est dur et
on a l'impression que gérard son camp
fait les temps faibles de maxime ont
enduré ont duré un peu trop longtemps en
fait
bref voilà on ne se rend pas compte des
carreaux découpés des coups de collier
je sais pas mais c'est que ça nous rend
cette impression de temps forts temps
faibles macha et ce qui est bizarre
c'est que tu crois au rush un moment
quand on remet en doute pendant des
années si on le fait sous l'eau et c'est
long ça part dans le sens icaew c'est là
aussi je pense qu'on tellement il se
désunit pas passer un de ses grands
tubes en août et tu te dis je dois
d'être peu plus d'1 5 + 1 g celle des
impressions je sois plus jusqu'à
l'infini après dix coups et que je perds
ouais mais il n'y a que plus ça et là je
pars bien on le croit plus à il revient
à égalité et peut-être ta merde c'était
le tournant j'ai raté mes jeux venant
pas de doute rien il est là regarde le
nombre de matchs lui revient dans d
armageddon dans des machins où il est
mené où il remet sous pression et contre
sochaux il a fait même s'il a perdu ya
ait encore une semaine mais j'ai en fait
il a va il a fait contre maximo skilling
open aussi phare il revient même quand
ils jouent moins moins bien que
d'habitude tu as l'impression aux alors
attends dam des deux rives a récupéré
quelque chose d'à max des trucs lin wen
en arrive à récupérer quelque chose au
pire au pire est donc non c'est sûrement
cloud secure encore pire mais bon je
pensais qu'il allait faire dame prend et
qui avait les progrès qu'il a les seins
qui a échangé les dames et ces écarts ou
qui va forcer les changes
bah ouais ça va faire nul ça à la savane
c'est sûr ça va venir faire le tour mais
on savait pour 5 arrive à la rescousse
du pion ce que maxime peut même
l'attenté avec les cavaliers qui joue
que sur une aile la position ferme et
baky ça
des fautes lourdes posées par les
professionnels et caro qui va sûrement
prendre des 4ème et il a bien vu que
maxime allez pouvoir tenter le truc et
il ferme la porte immédiatement
bon je sais très bien joué un apparat
d'hikaru lucine à l'égard de cavale ok
la tendresse
mais pourquoi pas jusqu'en très bien
joué parce que maintenant qu'ils avaient
lieu trois têtes huîtres faire bref un
bref un cavalier 3 et tu repars pas à
bouger deux cavaliers trois bennes ont
reproché de ne pas être payé en 3 il est
bien parce qu'il va bloquer le roi il va
attaquer ici il le met h 15 arrivée tête
carrée des f5 et décalé l'épreuve 3 1
sur sa juste au dessous des 4 ans je
dois aussi possible encore plus fort et
abandon ou le joueur français qui
revient à les allées bien celle là
combien de temps il reste pires 3,05 est
un peu comme tout à l'heure quand on
pensait que le match était fini qu'il
allait passer à plus 3 max qui répond
immédiatement qu'il faut réussir à fait
fou g5 pour attirer la donne a besoin de
15 débile mais efficace et toi bon
pourquoi pas facile alors 6 à u 6 à u
abandon c'est parce qu'il y avait le
pion qui file à dam
il n'y a pas de joie pendue peut-être
aussi que ça fait réagir
ycare voulait régler les déclarations de
maxime hier qui a dit qu'il trouvait le
format ridicule à cause de ça et que les
comptes ricard wii se permettraient de
la pendule à fond
batta sans nom mais choisir contre manu
respecte je fais pas contre toi je fais
quoi par contre les gens normaux je fais
pas contre toi je fais enfin un toit
c'est quand même de la broque de dire ça
après c'est justifié un mais je verse à
savez la fin c'est pas que ça met la
pression mais ça veut dire je sais qui
tu es tu vois ce que je veux dire ah
tiens là c'est pas mal puis ont franchi
les 3 il va tarder cavaliers affichent 6
et il va gagner le foucades noir alors
là d'amsterdam à chis ce serait matin si
on pouvait jouer deux coups alors quand
il déforme et noir parce que c'est pas
si facile ce genre de chose qu'un lieu
le 16 mars
tellement fort tellement il me faire que
tu aimes désistement c'est fragile c'est
fragile dames c'est un objet 4 je pense
fable je pensais plutôt dame g4 mais bon
mais ce que cette si fort sur x 4 vous
prend tout reprendre à me prendre à 9,6
il faut prendre tout reprendre peut-être
2005 il a lancé voici notre fou ou un
calendrier les c3 et je sais pas et on
verra ce que ça donne est-ce qu'on n'est
pas un peu mieux quand même mais bon on
n'arrive pas à attaquer les cases mais
quoique c'est qu'on peut réussir genre 1
dames 3 avec l'idée à un moment donné de
faire tour à 3 d'un match 6 tours h3 tu
as jamais de dire que stratégiquement je
pense qu'on jeu d'abord un petit truc en
plus mr j'aimais tellement d'amis on
n'avait pas bien ça qui est sûre les
colonnes on sent donc je suis pas sûr
qu'on soit mieux ils attaquent eu cinq
en vrai il force la finale entre nîmes
et très bon la sueur connais pas mieux
ouais c'est juste également on n'est pas
moins non plus quatre g5 un truc comme
ça
[Musique]
du coup tour c'est un bon échange tout
bon g5 j'imagine
il attend bien les 10 secondes de temps
pour poser nue dams a eu raison la pro
bien sûr beaucoup je tourne à 10 ans est
tombé cinq tours à 3 tours ce qu'ils
voient la cmuc direct un bus qui prend
bien son temps façon la cadence est
terminée il ya aucune garde à dire c'est
bien tu as roi de réfléchir comme dans
ta partie ce que j'aime passer de tout
et on se rend compte qu'au foot pour
opposer au jour en g3 g4 c'est sa voix
des choses comme ça arrêté écoute je
prends ma petite pause en même temps que
vas-y vas-y vas-y prend la pose
aujourd'hui on suit toi du coup il va il
va pas rester il va rester trente
minutes de deux bulles est pour pour
essayer de créer l'exploit côté côté
français est renversée hikaru dans la
cadence dans laquelle il est le plus
fort joueur français qui a une montagne
face à lui mais il faudra il faudra
l'emporter pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
remporter justement pourra gagner le
titre dans ce speech s il n'a pas le
choix le français il va devoir remonter
un point en bullet
c'est terrible ça va être ça va être
compliqué ça va mais très compliqué mais
bon bah on va espérer un va espérer on
va espérer qu'il y arrive et qui
réussissent à à renverser la table lab
le tas on pourrait dire ça comme ça on
pourrait dire ça comme ça avant j'ai un
peu lire le chat
j'ai envoyé la pub j'ai fait j'ai fait
ce que j'avais à faire pour renverser la
bleue talhaoui pas le choix écart ou
c'est un monstre en bullet ouais mais
bon sur trente minutes la forme du
moment la réussite
un point c'est pas énorme ça se remonte
un ca se remontent les gars il n'est pas
favori je vous cache pas mais ça peut se
remonter ça
peut éventuellement se remonter il
suffit devrait enfin ça se joue à rien
après les bulles atteint évidemment
écart où est le numéro un mondial dans
la cadence
il est très fort mais bon c'est là la f1
on peut le faire
les surprises sont sont faites pour
arriver un attrait l'exploit de remonter
ambulatoire après y'a qu'un point
d'écart un point c'est une partie c'est
une victoire
cc il gagne la première il ya égalité 1
donc tout est possible tout est possible
les amis tout cas il ya un titre
il ya un titre au bout aller chercher
pour le français lorsque sam est donc on
a mis un tout qui marche je vérifier moi
ya tout qui marche partout c'est super
j'ai un peu vos messages quelqu'un qui
j'y crois plus par un point c'est un
juge vraiment tu gagnes une partie suit
la prochaine partie à égalité quoi c'est
c'est rien c'est faisable
c'est même très faisable
je n'ai pas la barre d'évaluation pour
les avantages ouais ça ça force à
utiliser son cerveau pour poursuivre les
parties c'est vrai que ça peut être
dommage mais bon après c'est cool
c'est cool
tu peux rappeler comment se déroule la
finale bat là ça va être en tenue de 1
plus 1 donc il faut le faire jusqu'au
bout non mais là il peut il peut le
faire un jour expliqué pas de notes de
trucs bizarres de machin il ya beaucoup
trop de pour que son message en le chat
que je réussisse à les lire
j'ai hâte base la barre et se fasse trop
ah ouais mais quand tu mets la base en
fait ainsi la barre d'évaluation c'est
insupportable y'a plus personne qui
essaye de comprendre les positions alors
que en plus l'ordinateur il est pas très
fort et qu'on n'est pas capable de juger
que et que c'est complexe
allez une finale ça se gagne
allez une fois un beau mur là les
embaumeurs de fusées un mur refusé
qu'achille acquis par
mais après servir de la barre après on
pourrait on pourrait on pourrait on
pourrait commenter
on pourrait commenter les parties à la
barre à la barre d'évaluation ce serait
faisable mais mais c'est pas forcément
fin moi ça m'intéresse pas mais après je
peux comprendre qu'il ya des gens qui
aiment bien regarder une part
d'évaluation qui part vers le haut et
vers le bas ce face à un intérêt quoi
aussi mais moi c'est pas trop c'est pas
trop mon kiff perso après après chacun
sait qu'ils fin prêts chacun c'est kif
d'enghien
c'est un programme on pourrait faire un
point fr le three avec full barre en
gros quoi pour pourvoir que la barre
c'est plus marrant ne pas savoir
exactement ce qui se passe et de suivre
humainement la partie donc on a un cas
qui restent qui restent devant l'écran
je suis de retour
tu es de retour à temps je vais remettre
la carte c'est reparti à les y reste il
reste une demi heure
allez donc plus un sermon table
franchement ça se fait ça peut se jouer
à la forme ça peut jouer à l'énergie ça
peut jouer aux fusées ça peut jouir la
fusée 1
la fusée pour ces faits a fait diffuser
non il ya des ja de la fusée qui doit
partir on est très clairement mois en
bullet hikaru il est vraiment fort mais
après je veux voir ce qu'ils
s'intéressent tout le monde derrière
c'est que c'est un avis je suis chez une
amie qui est scénariste et c'est un peu
son lieu de travail et donc je sais pas
elle visualise comme ça mais plusieurs
intrigues plusieurs trucs
voilà c'est juste pour ça des post it il
faut un peu peut-être un peu de marloux
aussi de façon ça va aller vite
ça va aller très très vite à balan un
plus un ça super mutants voilà ça va
aller très très vite
faudrait déjà gagner à première et puis
je vois gagner une partie puis une
seconde puis toutefois de toute façon un
point enfin poing serré un tu gagnes la
première partie était déjà dedans pas
tirer une partie c'est égal quoi
c'est pas évident quand il nous fait
suer mais rennes fait tu nous fais et il
est bon il est très très très bon après
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
s'est un peu rapproché du 1 que ce soit
maxime ce soit wesley il ya moins
d'écart qu'avant mais après ça reprendre
en deux minutes
ok peut-être un peu de super bits ce
sergent un peu de super 8 c'est quand
même rapide super 8 6 et maxime vous
avec la vitesse deux super blitz ya
aucun risque ça c'est sûr rondeau dans
le temps comme ça il faut il faut avoir
espoir adéquat que maxime l'aude de
rugby
normalement on peut suffire ouais mais
bon les calmes et 200 grammes qui font
plaisir
il faut il faut tout donner
aller chercher à aller chercher la gagne
plus qu'une minute ça repart dans une
d'hikaru n'est pas là il est parti
non mais caron qui pourrait gagner pour
la troisième fois consécutive là ça
ferait ça ferait trois 3 tournée sera la
première fois qu'il gagne avec la
présence de magnus dans le tournoi alors
certes il n'a pas joué mais bon d'un
autre côté il est pour rien que ma
niçois fait éliminer avant donc je pense
que ça revêt une certaine importance
pour lui de gagner avec hikaru même même
sens le battre entre guillemets de dire
que cette année voilà il pas pour lui ou
qu'il pourra dire j'étais vraiment le
plus fort cette année quoi tout ça va
vraiment être le le moment hyper
important tous les deux là donc on
allait nord dans la première salle max
max qui enlève qui tombe la veste
allez mon max a laissé maintenant là
qu'il faut aller le chercher les speechs
sc une fois par an chez ascom qui
organise on va être deux gros événements
dans l'année entre guillemets c'est le
speech est celle approach hesling donc
l'appoint de chasse league c'est lors du
premier semestre et le pronostic fin
d'année e
mais ce pitch fin d'année ouais mais
même si je pense que l'année prochaine
le format sera un peu revu pour que ça
joue sur une période plus courte l'a
déjà ils ont voulu améliorer en faisant
jouer sur deux mois mais c'est encore
trop long en fait faut vraiment que ça
joue sur deux semaines maximum
en réalité run up up tu peux pas faire
un truc sur aussi longtemps on verra ça
c'est la donne
s'ils veulent en fait une sorte de com
de coupe davis à l'époque et je crois
que c'est tout ça et quand quand c'est
pour tout le monde fait court maintenant
c'est mieux ta huitièmes de finale
quitte à en jouer deux par jour en les
faisant en même temps les huitièmes de
finale tu peux l'aider vision de jour et
voilà m doutera match sur deux qui
tu sais aux taux avant le début trois
sur quatre au début tu peux tu peux
après faire comme ça va finir vendredi
samedi dimanche demi demi finale et
faire lundi mardi mercredi jeudi
huitièmes de finale les quarts de finale
en fait tu peux le faire sur une semaine
ou sur dix jours mais oui tu dois le
faire sur sur un truc plus serré
d'ailleurs là ce qui est sympa avec
cette fin de compétition c'est que ça
joue mercredi vendredi samedi et c'était
prévu pour être vendredi samedi dimanche
qui aurait été encore encore plus royal
de toute façon si maxime venait à perdre
aujourd'hui on pourrait toujours avoir
l'argument est on bien sûr matches sont
tellement je sais pas ce seuil est en
fait être bien sûr on sera jamais sûr on
sera jamais sûr et ça à partir mon fab
et pour tous les gens qui avaient mal ce
mas de question que j'aille dans le chat
je vous répondrai après je ferai un
petit post stream où je répondrai à vos
questions donc rester j'enverrai un raid
puisqu'elle plein de questions surtout
sur les échecs
ce sera après mes lacets maximale et
maxime faux important fable a
directement bim impact on le fait
reculer de 3 mètres hikaru il faut ils
font un arbre à thé de maxime ou cas au
gabon soit avec b3 dont il n'a pas du
tout joué 4 est relativement symétrique
parents larsen
je pense qu'il a pas grand chose à dire
on a un qui commence à se présenter à
tous rendez 8 il est bien max il est
bien sortie de l'ouverture à lille va
falloir être bon et donc à 10h25
probablement voilà il se cache et il va
rien il va revenir avec la tour on s'est
vite le fonds à six là il peut peut-être
peut-être créé des menaces il et il est
bien là note max il faut il faut trouver
il faut trouver les bons coups mais ça
se passera peut-être peut-être un e 5,5
b5 ya pas de clouage non mais sans
qu'elles aient fait voilà il va définir
d'ici cinq jours on peut repartir chez
nous car ou qui le chasse avant et j'ai
six là on a une case f4 on a des trucs
il va pouvoir rejaillir on espère en
tout cas peut-être s'ils réussissaient à
faire sauter le pion des quatre ans la
petite caste et 5 pour le fou
ce sera agréable et il a de la vence
autant ça c'est aussi important d'un
point 5 sais quoi de faire quoique et 5
j'aurais aimé qu'on prenne trois
viassoise mon peuple ouais on ne peut
pas y arriver mais fou des six attend ya
hd en l'air derrière sur f4 yade à me
prendre vraiment quatre balles et allez
ça peut rentrer attention hikaru hikaru
sous pression g4 non mais attends fou
quoi non mais c'est ça ça marche on
attend si ça ça marche
envie de chercher un voyage la dame se
défend fou b5 dame prend des cinq tempo
et damages six chars et leurs dépens de
laquelle gac
c'est incroyable ça c'est incroyable
hikaru qui est vraiment incroyable ils
menacent d'un étroit d'un prend b3 il
menace cavaliers g6 plus que dix
secondes côté hikaru aller maxime kg
système peut-être
ouais c'est parti tours 2 il ya pas un
truc avec un dame serait un échec
il fait de manger sain il joue le
clouage fkc adam prend j'ai capté c'est
gagner à l'essai égaliser fab s'égaliser
royal il revient il revient égalité fois
les envoyer des fusées la faune envoyé
de la fusée et du cac à la fonte belle à
la faune la flore il a fusé à fond
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer car
donc bien se passer ne t'inquiète pas je
vis en bullet je viens en bullet hikaru
tu l'as dit dans tes stream que tu
allais me casser les jambes en bullet je
viens pas seul j'ai avec mes kaki voilà
avec des amis sérieux avec des fusées a
été refusée avec les cas qu'ils allaient
max à l'effet fait l'exploit ce sera un
exploit tellement majuscule que tu es
arrivé de faire les deux de battre de
battre les deux les deux grands
champions numéro champion du monde
magnus carlsen est le numéro un mondial
entre guillemets sur le format hikaru
nakamura d'enchaîner les deux ce serait
quand même
aj caler mon maxi peut le faire la loi
sur le droit il est bien aidé en maxime
et regards regarde le temps hikaru qui
réussit pas à maintenir la vitesse de la
fusée française ariane est lancé c'est
terrible car il est qu'il y en a eu cinq
j'aime ce qui se passe avec moi tous les
chevaux un v6 de partout ouais j'ai 7,6
des f4 des tours v 5 d tout ce que tu g3
il va préparer ce 4l il va préparer
regard la tour en a si cela qui est
quand même venu défendre côté hikaru
c'est bien il maintient les 20 secondes
d'avancé hyperimportant fabuleux c'est
maxime que c'est sa seule sa seule
option a dressé devant autant tourbe et
cinq fantastiques qui veut provoquer b6
pour mettre la tour hors jeu sur la
sixième il attaque un peu ça il attaque
un peu là et ça y est le chaos qui
renvoyait des tactiques de partout mais
max qui semble savoir ce qui fait dame
f3 est ce que ça s'appellerait pas une
double attaque quand il ya encore floues
et 4 y'a pas un cavalier f si cela a non
il ya là tous racistes qu'ils contrôlent
c'est pas possible que si chaque boss si
c'est pas si clair passer sur mon mieux
pour les morts mais parce qu'il ya pas
si clair de pièces il a envoyé la dame
c-53 jeu ça tient pas de cavalier de 4
alors peut-être alors peut-être fable
qu'on récupère une tour une calloc'h
entre eux qu'à attendais pas car elle y
prend et f3 pour gagner gros
meilleur temps de l'autre tour ont fait
sauter oui il va prendre de l'eau tour
assez terrible ouais du coup tout
reprend ainsi s'il prend ici
ouais c'est dur c'est dur fab god je
sais pas trop il va pas faire un tour
d'essai pour cavani ce qu'ils veulent ce
cavalier 6 allée ne le voit pas ainsi
une deuxième fois une deuxième fois la
deuxième tour projet sept cavaliers
prend à achille ça va tomber là ça va
tomber mon job d'appoint g7
il prend g7 avec le cavalier non dame
française six ans il a encore fait mais
c'est sûr il y en a partout
contre 16 et il a mis ce clic max il
voulait faire il voulait pas faire la
tour ici c'est terrible le cas il ya
toujours du jeu il ya toujours du jeu
les pions h qui voit avancer je sais pas
il faut 3 pour défendre l été arrive
cette partie mon fab auprès du été
installé des barbelés au kg samir six
tours d1
il va gagner des deux il est gagnant la
femme qui les gagnants alors détour oui
certes les gagnants mais c'est très
chaud toujours oui très gagnant tour
action 3-7 tout va bien aller on va se
rate un peu plus fabre j'en ai raté une
contre un gamin ya pas longtemps qui
ressemblait vraiment à ça ou je me suis
fait de marloux t'aimer de folie mais a
laissé maxime cette fois ci j'en peux
plus là je peux plus commenter là c'est
fini je suis achats de voitures chez
hachette
bon il va il compte pour l'instant tout
va bien le pion sedona kahn s'est pas
trop peur on attaque look et qui se bat
faudra le bloquer comme un échec et on
peut avancer les résultats demain
oui oui car alios at il admis il les a
mises
il y à miss fab c'est extraordinaire o
le marlou info démarre loup dans le chat
la cafat c'est plus possible
on nous annonce en icaro grand favori en
bullet les gens qui partaient du live
pour pas voir ça et maxime qui prend le
devant à il est tellement plus fort que
lui ce soir
il est tellement plus fort fab or il est
tellement au dessus allez max faut tenir
jusqu'au bout maintenant jusqu'au bout
et au bout du bout y aura in your eyes
orale trophée allez plus que 23 minutes
femmes plus de 23 minutes les bordelais
veut garder le mur de barbelés
bah c'est pas encore demandé barlet fond
en comble être diffusé plus tôt faut
mettre des points mais la forme est allé
par des barbelés
ce sera la fin à la fin de la fin les
gens qui disent stop the 40 kw à taiwan
à bayota lot 6 gagnés par un vote un
vote près quel niveau de jeu il en train
de déployer maxime il est impressionnant
ce soir fou b5
et lui fait mal quand même il est juste
plus fort c'est juste un meilleur joueur
fab
après voilà il ya la fatigue al'avantage
d'hikaru sur la programmation et cetera
le privilège de jouer à domicile en
quelque sorte mais le joueur français
qui qui montre que les coffres dont
l'action ne plus de 100 fois option et
c'est bien qu'ils seront prêts la banque
était totale organismes viennent pas sûr
il ya eu un moment de flottement là on
s'en fout il n'y a pas de matière à deux
matches c'est très dangereux de ces cinq
lots revient de vérificateurs madame
c'est cette saison il couvre un petit
peu aller il va falloir d'un mec cathy
lâché simcoe qui fait plaisir il n'y a
pas un des cuatro là pour voile adéquat
trouve l'histoire il n'ya pas de
j'estime pour la détresse non détresse
importe quoi d tracy pas si détresse il
le fait à lévy bhl dans ta tronche à
l'écueil c5 qui part il va falloir ya
peut-être un peu trop et 17 après les
pressions se font sur ses intentions
attention attention il veut rentrer pour
aller mater pour l'instant c'est
dangereux ça va pas se le cacher mais
mais d'un autre côté dames quake iii va
te dévié il va te va permettre des
tâches 6 300 voix pour pour souffler à
plus de 20 secondes maxime qui fait tu
sais quoi il alla sera parfaite par
contre 1 il joue vite pour jouer contre
hikaru et est dan dan des quatre noms il
bloque un peu les cassettes ça devait se
passer de 5 ce juste vite voler bas
maintenant qu'il n'ya plus les dames gb
6 à 10 octobre
[Musique]
donc à idées sociales et surtout en b3
et la tour d2 et cavaliers pro b 4 ils
viennent à l'option ok bon ça avant
début faut pas se promène du coup s'il
faut tour des quatre noms des cadres à
tour ses toiles de l'économie en qualifs
et calais des cinq sécurité cav a lieu
trois lecavalier il aura déjà milieu de
fourchette tout à l'heure key c4 il veut
récupérer si tu récupères 5t quand même
content mais je pense que le pousser les
pions sur lui les a pas b3 bien b2b deux
allées plus pulpeuses et on est à tour
des quatre coins de quatre cavaliers des
deux allait tourner attendait 4 way
tourner autour des quatre tours des cinq
arrêts - ouais ouais mais non ça va pour
celle ci il a du talent temps max talent
tantale tantale temps mais j'ai peur
qu'il soit ou ait les mêmes si statu quo
hamilcaro 4 qu'on prouve à ceux plus
récents des chèques est un sport et jean
phi matin mais ça peut leur faire dire
facilement face qui je me trouvais de
répétition un truc comme ça
ok c'est répéter aller l'a mis les
barbelés à la fin ale max espagnols
comme dérive la devise spagnoli calais
il ya quoi il reste combien de temps il
reste combien de temps femme s'est
complètement irrationnel la main il
reste dix neuf minutes
ok c'est bien il tient bien quand même
le petit 2 0 pour attaquer les bullet
sadien saluant net sur la carafe des
supporters américains savaient pas si
attendre est une autre joueur français
soit si fort trahi les bons il est bon
le français c'est de ça
et c'est tout et c'est 3 allait
peut-être fou g5 bêtement comme huawei
non il faut qu'ils gardent cette
stratégie jouer plus vite
je veux jouer vite et bien quand c'est
assez simple en restant skis perd pas
juste beaucoup la mefou pranger cet
intermédiaire
je pense non autour ben ok dam des
quatre tours béart et j'avais vu comme
ça qu on va on report ne pas comme ça
ouais mais attend est ce que tu es ce
que c'est si grave parce que qui sait
pas s'il n'y avait pas ces biens seront
plus ouais non mais je veux des risques
on ne réussit pas le récupérer tu en as
non petit à petit peut-être ça fait
jamais plaisir un pion qui a cette envie
oui je peux dire c'est perdu
quelle horreur les faire bien maintenant
depuis plus rien aussi sa fin
ok bien je t'en pense un bon ok ça peut
être meilleur parti mais bon qui s'est
le moins bon ça peut la mer des côtes
ont d'abord 17 sur des chiens bergers
hockey est ce là pour souffler il ya que
égalité en gav
allez il faut revenir et bonne position
c'est simple tu reviens tomber sa dame
du vis-à-vis khulm à 602 hérisson il va
échanger les puzzles passe il devance
victor série de dessins qui va partir
fabas là ça va ça va aller ça ils
haïssent et bien mis en place dans
l'ouverture il a affaibli les les cases
les cases noires et le cavalier ou six
cavaliers f4 qui varient attention
windsor il faudrait que faire des cartes
ou aux quatre coins de masoe bien je
serai très content de la pression s
class et audrey six ans déjà
est ce que ces deux rencontres pas de
deauville allez vous prendre un petit et
g5 d'être reprendre un nom il n'est pas
du tout
me carole à qui mes pieds en maîtrisant
allait peut-être un quart des trois
quarts et légiste qui peut partir médina
un aveu que d'avoir fils espion j'aime
bien ta troupe rendre au quai dams et
trois intermédiaires c'est intéressant
ça parce qu'il menace qu'elle prend h
trois échecs au passage et il peut y
avoir des problèmes sur e1 et sur dame
français 3 français 3 il y aura un
problème
4 c'est quoi ce truc là pour prêter
chacun et tout reprend le 4 c'est quoi
ce truc tout reprendre quatre espaces et
glacières sûrement quelque chose ou pas
à temps et là il surtout 1.4 kg 5 on
tour 3,8 et mâcha hockey se jouer à tout
à l'heure
mais c'est un peu juste pour les blancs
attention très bien ça j'ai pas s'il a
raté quelque chose ou pas on peut nous
le gardons le chat ça nous a donné
l'impression mais là ces barbelés
voilà c'est compliqué là bas c'est
compliquer allait peut-être une tour en
b2 tomber d'eau qui essaie de récupérer
4 ème et là c est réduire de 37 euros 8
allée machin peut-être pas celle là
allez il faut aller la chercher d'abord
à lacets hikaru qui reprend un point
d'avancé reste combien de temps il reste
15 minutes
reste un gros quart d'heure dans tous
les cas quoiqu'il se passe pas on aura
vécu un match extraordinaire de la part
de maxime
en espérant qu'ils puissent qui puisse
nous à nous amener à la victoire des
écarts ou qui est loin d'être serein
ces gros matches ces gros matchs de foot
car outre il a aussi réussi à refaire la
balance au niveau de la pendule maxime
qui a réussi à jouer très vite dans
l'est dans les deux premières à le
mettre sous pression et caro qui a
réussi à réaccélérer quoi cela s'observe
un quart ou chiroma composée non là
c'est place et hikaru qui fait qui fait
mal alors est ce qu a infligé cinq
cavaliers aux 5 et sa part il récupère
b6 mais ça donne l'impression qu'il a
rien à y perdre des deux à la fin il
récupère des 5 e
c'est sur ces mêmes chinois renom qui
est même rien oui c'est ça on va te sais
rien faire attention puisque
inscriptions belle paire de fouiller les
trucs relou bon ok faut vraiment
s'accrocher pour l'année la tour 1 et
stopper cette hémorragie vraiment la
stopper sur dame ces trois ans on fait
quoi
ces trois roches à tour s'être observe
avec quatre matchs en six heures par un
cri de joie chez moi j'aime bien aussi
salué les bas du couloir ça dégage se
fout pas d'emploi ouais ouais ouais
c'est bien ça il attaque la tour on peut
voir occuper
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il est en train
de la retourner max j'ai parlé le bk de
diffa je suis content qu'il ait joué
j'ai l'impression que le b 4 avec les
six bons via airlie happé par un dos
cette course est et on peut pas ici
c'était si nous sommes champions
oui c'est une bien évidemment c'est
chiant et maxime qui cherche quelque
chose il va trouver firoud h 2 oui bon
c'est pas mal ça mettra les échelles il
va faire des quatre maintenant il attend
il attendait que la dame parte le fou
des qataris qui menacent quelque chose
peut-être fou quand j'ai sept toros et
le tour est vite
est-ce que ça va être là c'est parce
qu'il va après le truc c'est que l'autre
va faire dame en quête aux huîtres
offertes france et 8 soit aussi mais sur
belhanda échec chez patek
il ya des trucs qu'on n'a pas lu femmes
en tout cas ils attaquent ici menace
tour 8es chaque échec g3 et on échange
et robert ça va il fait des 8es tour
bien fou ça c'est étrange comme choix
c'est peut-être la raison
ouais moi fait l'autre moi aussi mais
bon ouais ça ça doit être nul un ouais
mais bon c'est à cause du bullet il va
te la jouer longtemps car on connaît et
il peut te presser un peu et tu te faire
des petits pas tout faire quand il a
battu saut et que juste aurait pu on a
quand même
après ici maximales pour pollution
je sais pas trop si peut trouver dans le
game accents proches catherine et ouais
mais voilà ben voilà enfin le roi faible
et où sa voix si on lâche 3 ou je sais
pas quoi
pour machin ouais tu l'auras c'est
terrible parce qu'on a vu le piège on
pouvait rien y faire baisser ce moment
battance encore son portable salon où
s'était pas tout rage suite ici patrice
est plus taxé déjà perdants mais je sais
pas facile pas sûr cependant ces
trois-là au web complexes allez c'est
pas fait le tour h4 on l'a vu vie en
plus et allemands ont bien joué de la
part du caroux d'avoir trouvé ce piège
ouais mais c'est son gros point fort 1
aller 2 points d'écart il reste quoi il
reste dix minutes à l'efsf adossé ici
déjà parti il reste quinze parties ouais
il reste quatre parties
donc il faut il faut vraiment plus
perdre aucune raison de faire cette
partie on a une pression très correct
après bon aller taquiner pour gagner on
verra quelle est roi en face en laye
karoui karoui des rentrées il est rentré
en mode position qui vous longtemps pour
faire des droits
ouais longtemps il t'est jamais je te le
dis tout de suite il est parti en mode
ouais par un carreau qui est partie en
mode en mode gros caïds et 3 pour ces
deux autour d un jeu pas au québec
d'ailleurs les quelques remarques
épreuve janka s'est fait recadrer la
samo spectateurs en quatre ans recule on
avance on recule
peut-être un temps
l'essai encaissé 50 kgs c'est un machin
il veut te propose donc il aurait cas
ici c'est un coin pour échanger battini
troqué ses charges pas trop fort et
cargo se serait inscrit qu'il est
extrêmement fort je sais pas
ouais mais parce que y ambühl est là il
fait plus d'erreurs et il te met la
pression est extrêmement fort et non
mais j'ai des trucs où il ya rien à
faire il juste à jouer à ne pas faire
d'erreur et ont provoqué ce sont les
normes près fort pour l'espoir flachau
et cela très très mal mais on m'a dit
voilà il est vraiment très mal oui le
roi est coupée il ya 10 et blesse il ya
un pur moins bien sûr y aura pas de toi
j'attendais 8 km et 7 aux pires dérives
peut même faire perf est à dire s'il
avait eu envie quoi oui c'est une sorte
de balle de match phare ou pas donc j'ai
bien sûr exemple ça sera terminé enfin
kelly g7 encore mais 5 et séoul yang
maxime qui abandonne pour se laisser du
temps
bon bah écoute faut faire du 100% mais
non le moindre duel je pense que delphi
ouais je croyais alors là il a été
extrait exceptionally cas où la maxime
vous ne pourra pas s'en vouloir un
qu'aura vraiment aura sorti le grand jeu
voilà ça me balance ça me paraît à plus
de j'y croyais encore
mais maxime aussi qui est problèmes de
connexion un petit peu aller ça revient
on aura un beau match maxime maxime
extraordinaire et encore une petite
chance on va y croire mais dans tous les
cas maxime maxime sortira au pire des
cas la tête haute un oui avec un mâle
toile attendre quand même on sait jamais
qui joue vite et chasser ce que tu
disais aussi c'est qu'ils caron
impression qu il en a perdu 2 est en
fait au lieu de s'énerver mais rate plus
accros au web ouais c'est impressionnant
le mode turbo face aux cheveux je pars
ouais c'est quand même fait il toujours
en vie l'attend une minute tu as
l'impression qu'ils joueraient à 26 feed
quasiment fin ok j'exagère mais il te
jure twin stendhal c'est fini moi je
crois que c'est mathématique en chine
c'est mathématique bon écoute bord du
chaos extraordinaire
pourtant les deux parties perdues qui
était peut-être évitables ouais mais vu
le scénario du bullet je pense qu'on n'a
pas voilà le match dans tous les cas
liqun hikaru méritas n'ya pas y'a rien à
dire il fait un superbe match
beaux vainqueurs 1 quand même hikaru no
25 m qui fait quand même beaucoup pour
les échecs aussi un faut quand même le
dire pour finir sur une note positive
sur les carreaux tout de même avec ces
stream et tout et tout ce qu'il peut
faire et tout ça c'est que c'est un beau
vainqueur et c'est c'est quelqu'un qui
fait quand même beaucoup pour pour les
gujanais à dire sur lui la manière
barbatus hotu avec ces trucs d'attentes
personne n'a trop aimé mais c'est comme
ça et rien d'illégal d'air mais en soi
écoutes qui l'a volé personne et il fait
beaucoup à ça que c'est stream tout ça
très très beau joueur bongo à qui a été
numéro 2 mondial en partie longue quand
même faut le faut le rappeler si avait
pas eu magnus y aurait peut-être eu une
carrière un petit peu dit
quentin il était vraiment dans l'ombre
de magnus en partie longue qu'ils
acquièrent en plus sa bête noire au delà
de ça non seulement légale numéro un
mondial et en plus c'est les styles qui
correspond pas ouais et comme les
vallées vanille car oui car ok quand
même numéro un mondial en blitz en
classement réel aussi c'est quand même
pas rien il a gagné des grandes chez ce
tour il a gagné beaucoup de choses il a
un beau palmarès et et ce soir ils
étaient plus forts il n'y a rien à dire
et pourtant
mais j'ai envie de te dire c'est si
proche et si l'on à la fois c'est que
t'es pas loin et quand même les quelques
coups d'accélérateur mis par hikaru
impressionnant la la fin peut-être que
même si on gagne nos deux pour finir
mais que de toute façon un maximum grand
maximum il reste trois parties mais
normalement il n'en reste que deux mais
en fait j'ai envie de te dire dans un
miracle au total il en reste 3 il ya
quatre points d'écart donc ou nombreuses
normes et en plus il en resterait trois
sicav ou abandonnés ou quoi mais faites
vite le fait que façon il fait tourner
la pendule va pas c'est normal ça 5 3
minutes tu vas pas tu vas pas aller au
bout et là ils maximisent leur trouver
un truc
ouais encore trouver un trick non et non
non c'est alors très compromis sa
position il a sauvé sa peau
non mon beau vainqueur vainqueur et
cargo avec un format comme on le dit
taillé pour lui mais après j'ai envie de
te dire est ce que les partis donc sont
taillés pour magnus carlsen enfin voila
c'est un format internet c'est un joueur
spécial izard est c'est enfin le forum a
été fait comme il a été fait c'était pub
pour faire pleurer quand non mais j'ai
envie de dire le sucre au site est le
meilleur en rapide si en blitz sur
internet tous les formats qui rompt des
plis sur internet seront taillés pour
toi quoi qu'il en soit et roth gambie
mondiaux pour finir au beau jeu le plus
tôt toi le plus important que maxime
évidemment sera fat échange un million
de ce pitch est contre une victoire au
candidat donc max qui s'éclate avec un
petit gambie moudio on donne tout pour
écolo 910 fraîche ciselée foucher pack
web et maxime qui aura une belle belle
place de finaliste belle deuxième place
et ont quand même éliminé au passage le
champion du monde avec le parcours aura
été quand même beau les carreaux qui
aura écrasé tous ses adversaires avant
d'arriver en demi contre 101 qui a été
le match peut être le plus dur pour lui
finalement ce soir
wen dans la même veine les comptes
ricard où j'avais contre sceaux j'ai
vraiment pensé avant le match que sow
aller le aller le taper 1
c'est ce que le style lui correspond pas
du tout à ce style de ce grand écart
ouais j'ai pensé que soient les le
allait le prendre
l'ascension qui faisait tellement tourné
la pendule pourrait vraiment moins deux
parties c'est là contre maxime rey après
non c'était un match très très chaud en
fait ça se joue à rien mais en bullet
sacré client chacun sait donc où maxime
qui a fait un beau tournoi
une femme baroud d'honneur mais même là
hikaru no cry bien défendu il a salué
pour avoir du matériel pour et ses
saveurs plus rien et le victoria qui
s'était fait encore frais nouveaux trucs
fous ces deux à la fin et on reprend le
cinquième à une barrière je crois sont
pareils de la fin du temps c'est dommage
que ça fasse autant enfler le score quoi
enfin bon c'est pas grave que tu perdes
d'un point ou cinq points mais c'est
vrai que ça oui du coup ça fait un score
sévère vu le match mais c'est sévère
maxime fine à 3200 plus même et c'est en
bullet en ces classements bullet et en
fait c'est un autre classement elo
complexe
complexe femme peut être l'an prochain
il a montré des belles choses après un
message à battre magnus c'est quand même
pas rien du tout c'est un truc énorme
et aujourd'hui c'était pas trop loin
mais ni caroux dur sur internet et dur
pour maxime et on va parler de ce match
up entre les deux
ben en fait il a tout le temps perdu
c'est ce que disent en fait ses membres
puisque magnus bat toujours hikaru enfin
presque
hikaru pas toujours ses maximes et
maxime joue pas mal contre magnus
ouais ouais c'est marrant quand ces
genres de tryo où les ou led zep sont
pas et donc dans le ricard outil encore
ouais c'est un pierre feuille ciseaux en
fait mais du coup est dans l'histoire
car nissan reste plutôt favori pierre
pataugeant rencontre avec ces mots clés
il peut perdre qu'à gagner dans les
autres sans cesse à sens unique aux
soucis pour ça qu'ils champion du monde
du coup passe un peu le puits en scène
dans l'histoire ouais et sow se seraient
enregistrés piaillent fait aussi avec
sow et avec 1 puis quoi terrible quoi et
du coup la feuille est assez forte à
quand ils puissent elles gagnent contre
2 au 6 mai les ciseaux et les cailloux
qui diana c'est mieux qu'en fait tu vous
que puis ou feuilles
ouais mais bon quand tu es petit tu
comprends rien d'autres jouent au hasard
mais si tu réfléchis un peu mais le puil
a rien à faire dans ce jeu qui a monté
seul payet puissant que la pop aussi
c'est au big bang theory quand ils font
un pierre feuille ciseaux un terrible
du coup tu vas sur big three à la presse
ouais il s'est fait répondre à quelques
questions et puis après je vais manger
ouais ça va faire une petit nul natation
n'ont même pas si j'allais faire un nom
sur rémunérés même pas même pas bon
peut-être sur le thème du vin jours pas
tout de suite
ouais je lançais comme le match était
fini qui avait juste prendre là nul pas
même par la balle hors les points d'eau
sont importants les caissettes voulons
aller à dame un ff d'affaires de 1 à
kadam ans et sept neveux cavaliers h kg
5 qui vont l'empêcher dames c'est un
ouais mais adam and there 3 et 4 je suis
vraiment basse et d'affaires aux détenus
le wave monter là haut tu prends quand
même des normes le rythme est bon oui
c'est comme le match il a atteint son ca
risque relatif
ça reste pour la partie pour le match
elle n'est pas d'homme c'est 2 fois 4
donc probable annuel philip sion
bon c'est bizarre quand même je sauverai
genre sens qu'avec les blancs tu risques
que de la perte d'un proche
ouais 5 sélections va pas l'éclaté de
jouer non plus ouais mec changé je veux
juste faire nul en a marre quoi mais
madame brand est maintenant un bon
orateur autres organismes non seulement
on possède la partie la plus longue du
match c'est de là que ça du tout
terrible qui a fait n'importe quoi là
max voalavo ouais ok bac on est libre on
y voit là et non un grand bravo quand
bravo à lui il a il a vraiment fait le
match le match qu'il fallait mais
emerson hauser suis dit d'arrêter avec
nous cette finale pour la demi-finale
pour tous à des beaux murs j'ai vu des
beaux murs et bravo au maximum tout cas
qui a bien fait vibrer tout le monde
nous a fait vibrer ils n'ont plus cours
aujourd'hui mais c'était pas loin
très beau match bien battu j'utilise
tombé sur un ratio plus fort mais c'est
comme ça ça me sépare mais je crois que
c'était les mots de la fin fab merci
d'écouter fini c'est bien simple estime
tous ensemble et puis pendant ce trou
lundi quoi oui à lundi fab josh howard à
tous merci merci à la saveur un peu un
peu la déception est à dakwa là ont su
ont su voilà à tanger couper le stream
et je relance et de l'autre côté